This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina [inaudible].
We are making
music.
It's called a home button.
Oh Carson,
very goth.
I got a announced add on date.
Okay.
We're adding a show in Tampa,
tampon Florida at the
Tampon theater March 7th.
This is a March 7th will be the
added show is our third show there.
That's very exciting for me.
I'll tell you a couple of
maize. I'll tell you a couple other
things that are happening. Uh,
with the new tour number one,
uh,
the first show will be January 4th,
San Francisco that may sonic
the January 5th one is sold out.
So if you want to go in San Francisco,
you got to get tickets to the fourth.
It's not the May sonic, it's the masonic.
Sorry. He said, man, that's very,
very stupid of me. I'm a
stupid person. Thank you.
We also have, uh, the see the early,
uh, the 11th in San Diego is sold out.
The 12th early show is sold out.
There is about 150 tickets left
to the late show in San Diego.
If you want to go from there,
I go to Oklahoma City to show on the 22nd
has tickets, the other ones are gone.
And then San Antonio, Houston and
Dallas, you'll want to get on those. Um,
all of them are either close to sold
out or sold out. So if you're in Texas,
that's what to do. The
following is the, excuse me,
the next time I go out after
that will be Long Beach,
a Chumash casino in Reno.
Those are all on sale.
And don't forget I moved the show.
That was in November,
uh, at the Welmont in Montclair, New
Jersey. I moved it to February 13th.
That was due to weather. It was
snowing that day. Unexpected. And uh,
the road's shut down anyway,
that shows now February 13th,
if you can't go and you had tickets, you
get a full refund. If you want to go,
your tickets stay valid. So just show
up and you'll still have the same seat,
but there will be a few more tickets
available now that it's been moved.
So if you're interested in
going, it's February 13th, um,
gene, which I believe it's
February and don't forget,
we also a late show in Nashville
or field Tennessee at the Ryman.
So that's um, on Sunday that we
can April during the festival,
the first show sold out, we added a
late show at the Ryman. Oh shit man.
You know when you push a fucking button
and then your ass hole goes all weird.
God Damn.
Yes.
Uh, so Philly filler up.
Delphia I'm on my way. Browse.
I'm leaving on Thursday. I'm going to
see you guys December 7th. Fill her up.
Delphia some tickets left on that Friday.
Late show. The first one is sold out.
Thomas that down Friday. Late show,
right jeans. Always the Friday late.
It's such a pisser never stops.
It never stops. Do Door titties.
Uh, like literally maybe 20 tickets
left so that like a Brit lit,
truly let Trillium to anti
tickets left on December 8th,
the Gramercy theater in June.
Dork titties January 10th.
I'm here in the main room at
the comedy store in Hollywood.
January 31st through February
2nd Denver at the comedy works.
February 28th and Madison,
Wisconsin, the comedy club on state,
and then many apple tits.
April four through six.
And then we're looking at may
at the Tempe Improv, Tempe,
Tempe.
And I've,
I'm waiting on a date to reschedule the
Ceylon slolum false date that I had to
cancel due to the fires, the
crying tour. Right. Anyway, uh,
this is the writer day tour.
Thank you to everybody that's already
come out and I look forward to seeing you
very soon. Christina p online for
ticket links. Thank you Jesus Spine.
Thank you so much.
Christina [inaudible] online,
[inaudible] dot com you know what it is?
Y'All know who's good to game be g.
Okay.
I don't know what it is.
God do the thing because there it is.
You know what I'm saying?
That, uh, you know what I'm saying?
Welcome to the podcast.
No, I'm saying, um,
today's episode is absolutely amaze.
You have so much great material for
you, great guests. It really is.
I know we say that a lot,
but today you might sour
and saucier jeans. So
what did you say? Sour and saw some,
did you hear that and made it up?
You just made that up with your
dog, right? Yeah, we got a dog beer.
Demetra professional comedian.
Yeah, you're a lady comic
now I'm a comedian. Okay.
Don't fucking make up my pronoun
for me. Don't you gender me? Yeah.
All you're switching glass.
I got to switch cause that's for readings
and then this is just a general oh
cause you're old. I'm so
old. Wow, that's cool. Yeah.
I didn't know how old she
was. Anyways, grow up Tom.
Christine's old and we're ready
to do this episode. Ready?
Oh your jeans up.
Broward Sheriff's office says Wilson
and the man got into a verbal over her
quote farting loudly.
Boys want to see that on TV?
Fall in line.
And that is when she pulled a knife and
threatened the man before leaving the
store.
Don't bring it
to your mom.
So
I got it.
I got to
tell you right now. I got to tell
you, I get it. I kinda like the Armos,
the Greeks,
the guineas,
the blacks had been wearing these Valore
tracksuits for years and the Hungarians.
Momo, the crime demo. You
got me one? Yeah, I'm wearing
it right now. It's great.
Right? It's really comfortable. Yeah.
Can I tell you? Oh, I get it. Yeah.
And nothing makes me happier.
If you want to get me any gift,
anytime the Nova Lore tracksuit me, it's
so soft. It's the fucking bomb. Right.
The ease of it. The parents. Yes.
Easy to take on and off this.
Aw. Yeah, I'm jealous.
I kinda, I want one.
The problem with the ladies versions, they
always make them too tight. Oh, right.
I'm saying like sexy. Juicy. Yeah,
but you want it loose and comfy. Yes.
I may have to get like a men's comfort.
Comfort over. Yeah, of course the,
but I'm so happy that you're filing on
board with the velocitor showed up with
one yesterday. No, I've been trying to
ease you into this shift for 14 years.
What does it take is fine. I
just put it on. I mean, what a,
there wasn't hard to convince me.
I know,
but I feel like I've bought you
these things over the years.
Haven't not full full Valore. I just know.
You know why I felt like it was time.
You're ready for it. Why? I don't
know. I feel like now that your dad,
your father of two, yeah, you're
officially in dad mode. You're like,
yeah, I'm so happy. I'm so happy.
And I wore my three stripe
just to commemorate.
I feel like we're in it to get where
we're like total eastern blockers now.
We are.
Um,
so this lady farted and then all the
knife on somebody or for talking about her
fart.
That crazy.
Really wild out of flatulence and a
Florida store leads to police making a
stranger rest. It's a lot of
purple Chanetta Wilson notion.
Their Shahada,
she was arrested for aggravated assault
with a deadly weapon after she pulled a
knife on a man who was offended when she
allegedly passed gas while waiting in
line. So she farted somebody
who was like, Hey, do you mind?
And then she pulled a knife on him.
Fuck you off far one on one a fart.
The Broward Sheriff's office says awesome.
And the man got into a verbal dispute.
Oh her, her quote, farting
loudly. Boys on to say that on TV.
Tang loud. And that is when she pulled a
knife and threatened the mandible there.
Laughter here. Yes, I
did. Far Tang and loud.
Loud
play it again.
Yeah, it was great. Far
tarting. Loudly. Farting.
Loud. Loud. Why did she get
of a flatulence by the way,
such a Dick. I have.
Usually when they only,
if there's a fart story involved.
Does the anchor person ever say like
there's the person when their image comes
up like she did, she was like,
they're like, they never do that.
Well because it's fart related.
They're like, there she is.
She's mocking the credit.
She's a serious crime though.
She pulls a knife on
fucking aggravated assault.
Of course they're Chanetta. They're
shutting you tick. Yeah. We know.
Like our son now, our oldest son
is going Yay. Just out of nowhere.
It was yes. Forever.
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Jeez.
Like your lunch. Yay. He sounds
like the guy from sexy beast. Yeah.
Yeah. He's um, loud.
It's like someone learning
to say the word loudly.
Farting, loud. Farting, farting, loud.
Loud.
I fart loudly.
A lot in public.
I can't hold them in any more after
two children cause I, you know,
when you have a vaginal birth it
kind of loosens everything up. Yeah,
that's pretty wild.
You're, uh, your farts.
It's really been so hard to look at you
because you've been cutting your own
hair. Hey, let's talk about it. It's
terrible. Let's talk about what happened.
So I want to post the
photographs on my Instagram,
the Christina piece so you guys can see
what I'm dealing with. So last night,
is it the Christina?
I do the Christina
there.
Shanana
it's the Christina p instead
of the worst social media.
Any huddles.
I was relaxing last night.
You always did this to me when
I'm like having my glass of wine,
I'm chilling down.
You come downstairs and you're like,
you're bald. You look like
Bruce Willis. And I'm like,
what the fuck did you do to yourself?
Because you,
you've been cutting your
own hair with your clippers.
I get impatient and impulsive and I
just, sometimes I just, here's the thing,
because my balding is in the front.
What happens is like when you take it
down all the way, you're like, cool,
it's this, this, this is how it
should be. As it starts to grow out,
what stands out is that the
front center is obviously thin,
so it stands out that, oh, everything else
is getting longer, starts to look bad.
Sometimes it'll be like a second or
third time. You look in the mirror like,
I got to do something about
it now. Oh, I see. So what?
What's happening is because
I don't mind that, that you,
you're cutting your hair short. It's
just that you're doing it, like you said,
impulsively in poor lighting at night,
so you're not,
you're missing a lot of spots.
You're not really doing a good
job. Yeah. You, why not wait?
Because Alan's coming over tomorrow.
He's going to be in your house and he
can do your hair properly. First of all,
I didn't know Ellen was
coming over. I didn't make an
appointment with him. Right.
I just saw what happened was I saw how
thick. Okay, so I start to see that.
Then I start to see how thick the beard
gets. My beard will get really thick.
I'm also going to post that on Instagram,
on the Christine and p.
You guys can see what I saw in the bowl
when I went to go brush my teeth the
other day. Half your dirty disgusting
whiskers. We're in the ball. It's,
well let me ask you,
I understand you take half of it now but,
but the thought it doesn't occur to
you like maybe I should maybe clean the
whiskers. I did. I did.
Eventually eventually it did.
If you go look in the sink,
it's clean.
It doesn't make you sick to
leave it there. And initially,
not initially because I'm not done yet.
Do what happened was I did a pass on
the beard and then I came downstairs and
then I was like Ah, I got to do
the head note. Went back upstairs.
I think you saw it in between the two.
Then I did the head, then I cleaned up.
It was an all day thing cause I was in
the afternoon or the kind of afternoon.
No, no, no, it was both were
in the evening. Oh, okay. Okay.
You said you didn't notice the beard
until you like I'm saying my beard change
until you notice the head
change, so, right. So what you,
you call me upstairs and I'm already
been drinking so I'm by drinking,
I mean I have my one glass of
wine palm juice nosedive too.
And so that's when you hand me
the clippers and you're like,
can you clean me up? And I'm like, Hey,
no, because the lighting's terrible.
It's nighttime be, I'm
already a little bit, yeah.
Sauced yeah. Okay. Uh,
three I don't cut hair professionally.
I can't do anything better than what
you're amazing is how badly you have
adapted to just neck trimming over years.
Like I have neck
and on my neck tremor, you know,
it's just one of these like little,
the trimmers, you know, I mean
a wall or something, tremor.
And you still hold it backwards
and the wrong way. I'm like, look,
it's either like this or like this.
And I give it to you and I always
see you go the wrong way. I'm like,
how many times am I going to ask you?
Because every time you ask me to do it,
I'm already been drinking or it's
bedtime and you're pulling me out of bed.
You pulled me out of bed last time,
eight months pregnant to do it,
nine months pregnant. And, and then you
got mad at me that I didn't do a good job.
I was tired, I was almost
asleep. And you're like, come
trim my hair. Well anyways,
so last night I go and I look at
your head and I see it in the end,
the damn bathroom light.
And I'm like,
you got to see what you've
been walking around with brow.
Well block it around for an hour,
but still it's bad enough.
And I take a photo chunks,
just long shocks,
patchy scrap.
And then I'm looking at your beard now
and it's not good. I gotta be
honest because listen, just listen,
it's patchy as fuck on the sides.
And then when,
and then you left a Brussels beard,
like a schnauzer beard down here.
So this is, it looks like
a goatee. Good. It looks,
it looks like you cut a goatee on
your beard. It doesn't look good.
People like it. Nobody likes
it compliments all day to
day. It looks terrible.
It looks so good. And how the fuck did
you do this? You did this with your dog.
Clippers with your head clippers. You do
this with your beard. No head clippers.
I just threw on a different garden. Went.
Yeah. It shows that you just read judges.
You just Willy Nilly you wiggled
your rest around and that,
that looks awesome.
Yeah.
Well I'm a tell Alan the clean that
beard up me really fucked that shit up.
I did not really fuck that shit up com.
It looks like you look like
good morning Julia and the Frat.
I don't look like Joe.
You've got the,
it's like a long schnauzer beard in
the front. My flower, my every Tang.
Me You yesterday.
I can't stop thinking about him.
It's amaze. I can't stop thinking
about Joe. Come on and Julia,
you yesterday.
Meet me my soon to be my everything.
My soon to be my
everything. My flower. Ah,
the kiss is just the worst.
Um, me, you, well, a couple
of things. First of all,
don't go back to your boyfriend.
We didn't do this on the podcast because
I didn't know if it would be a bad idea
to do on the podcast because
of the reach of the podcast,
which is we held a screening for
instant family in thousand oaks.
Let me, first of all, my husband
is very humble and sweet.
Let me tell you what my
husband really is saying,
that when the oak park shooting
happened and then the fires happened,
it was horrible.
And my husband bought out a theater so
that people could go see instant family.
You buy it up all the tickets so that
we could host a free screening for the
Community of Oak Park. That's what you
did, Tommy. Cause you're a sweet man.
Thank you. Um, what I was trying
to say was that I did not do that.
I'm just being fair here. What I was
saying was that I would charge people dub.
I've, what I did was I wanted to do
it in that community, but I, I, um,
I only announced it on social media
cause I didn't know if we did it on the
podcast.
You have a limited number obviously,
of tickets for a movie screening. Right.
And if I announced it on the podcast,
I didn't want like too many people to
show up and be disappointed because I felt
like the podcast response
would be even crazier.
I just announced it on Instagram,
Twitter,
and Facebook and we held it
on Sunday and people came out.
They were extremely
nice and grateful and so many mommy's
such a respectful audience. And you know,
most of them came up to me and told me
they enjoyed the movie and the movie's a
well done movie for the, uh, for sure.
Like a family kind of came on the screen.
Everybody clapped.
But that was very funny. People would
clap when my name would come up,
when I would walk on swear. They were
like, Whoa, that's very funny. Um,
but thank you guys for coming out.
I really enjoyed doing that. Um,
it was very fun actually. Uh, we had
our friends kind of weight. Yeah.
Cousin Bree. Bree came, Ryan
sickler sickle cell was there.
Who Stavo who plays a horn and your
movie was there and Rena and Matt. Yeah.
That was really fun. That was a good time.
Um, what else did I want to tell you? Oh,
this other thing,
I mean has taken off.
If you don't know over the
weekend, Garth's, Notre Dame
for fuck's sake. You're just
going to walk into this. So
many, there's so many. First of all,
when he was saying as the week
was building up, Holy Shit,
his Instagram is over.
I didn't realize there was one
thing where I did where I go,
I opened one of his posts and I go,
I want to scroll through the comments,
see how long it takes to see a non
related comment.
I couldn't find, it was just like scroll,
Scroll, Scroll through. I was like,
Geez. I was like 50 comments in
nothing to do with him. You know
about our show and the people
who listen to us. Yeah. Is this
the best? Number one, there's nothing
that compares fun. We have a common,
we have a common target here. Come
here. All right, so here's an idea.
So you post this about
his Christmas music thing.
Miss your wood here was like, there's
nothing bad spending Christmas together,
right? And then you
open it up. Hey Hitler,
will you guys be performing the classmate
Christmas song machines within? If not,
you guys should try it out. Keep
them high and tight, right? No,
there actually is real common,
sweetest couple ever.
Then it says keep it high and tight.
Hashtag dedication.
You are not Gareth and Trish
doesn't look like either. Um,
so that's one there.
Now here's his Notre Dame post gene,
high and tight. You want to move in?
You could move it a try it
out. Oh my God. It's just like,
it's relentless fans of the podcast.
I listened to troll Garth Brooks.
I was starting to pick up,
started to pick it up.
Open your heart to me in your arms.
Just like Joe, you don't need lube.
You need to spit.
Oh my God.
You don't need, you don't need spit.
Yeah, that's right. Um, here's his head.
All you post. Well, it's official.
We're on Facebook. I told,
Gee, and he didn't believe me. He believes
me. Now it's just endless. It is endless.
I mean, every post to every
single post is like this God,
what the fuck is going on here? This girl
wrote, what is going on? I'm confused.
Physical four strokes. What the
fuck? And then someone wrote,
he just wanted a poop through a hammock.
I said, why not? It's just like the gays.
That's their explanation to someone
who was like, what's going on here?
Are you planning to release B side
version of this album with just Trish
blasting carts into the mic?
And by the way, every time I've
seen, uh, cause I follow him,
I'll just, every time a new
post comes up, within seconds,
it's completely,
completely
just getting pummeled. Piss
on me, beat me, try it out.
Or asking them, how often do you miss
your would go full throttle. Jesus.
Yeah.
It's endless.
If you really want to be
amused by who is Julia?
Good Morning Juliet.
I could see you use your lung
disease as an instrument,
maybe even playing machines
within for the mommies.
How you're only takes forester.
Somebody wrote $100 as
Garth is a ball hall.
I'm not sure what that means.
I like the interaction though,
like the confusion.
Oh my God,
God,
I got friends and mom's places where
the jeans are tight and Burt is racist.
That's hilarious. Yeah, so if you
really want to have a good time,
check that out. Oh God,
no. But it's just, it gets,
so that's just the beginning of my
last few days with Garth on Instagram.
So he's been promoting that CBS
concert that aired on Sunday night.
And let me just say it was
the most unnatural video.
Do you have that one? Can
you pull that one up? Oh,
the one where he like introduces that.
He's doing a concert.
We're going to fill this up.
[inaudible]
here's my room again before anyone.
Garth Brooks is undoubtedly talented and
he makes millions of people happy with
what he does. We're not crapping on
this guy, his talent or anything,
but the social media component needs
to be managed where he's like, can you,
can you believe this work?
We're going to feel this.
Oh, it kills me is the fake, the
fake humble pie of it. Like, well,
we're going to, we're
going to feel it. Like,
of course you are your agent book to you
in an arena tour because you're going
to sell all these tickets, asshole.
He was doing all this promo
for this, uh, you know, cause it was a
seep televised event. Let's be crazy.
And I saw him doing this interview where
he was like, well first, uh, you know,
you're scared because a, you're like,
are we going to even be able to sell it?
May tickets. And he goes, and then it
sold out in an hour and you're like,
so you're like, you dick, like so nervous.
But then an hour later it was all sold
out. Well, it's the, yeah, the fake.
Like I just can't, I don't know if we're
going to be just happy anyone showed up.
Just humble pie.
He's not the,
the number one entertainer of course,
in the world right now.
Yeah. That's such weird ever held at
legendary Notre Dame stadium. Yeah.
I got friends in Notre Dame stadium.
Oh boy.
Five at Notre Dame to
knock after a 60 minutes.
And the thing is too,
like it doesn't,
he have other highly successful
songs other than I've got
friends. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. I think that's, that's
the, that's his anthem.
That's the same joke over is that yeah,
I've got friends in Notre Dame
stadium. Yeah. Well they have to do,
it's so weird too because
you imagine like his, uh,
his fans obviously like his hardcore fans.
I think that's a hilarious, that's a
funny joke. Sure. Yeah. They're like, Huh.
Cause he's got a song called,
I got friends
the agile,
see he did a joke about it like that.
Huh?
What's this richer reminding you to
tune into CBS is Sunday a Sunday eastern
seven central. Right. Don't
miss live at Notre Dame.
Garth Brooks is going to be fine. Gold.
Yeah. He just doesn't know how to do it.
Hey everybody, I just going to
tell you, hey, he's so awesome.
He's a great performer. Yeah. Amazing.
Just like a weird social media guy. Yeah.
Really, really weird. Really. And
how are we going?
Are we going to fill this up?
But the thing that we all suspected
is actually true.
That's the last time you're ever going
to see him perform a concert because
apparently it's all over.
It's all over. Okay.
Because this came out this morning. Oh,
okay. This was on the news this morning.
Okay.
You want to see it all right?
Yeah. I'm, I'm upset. I'm upset already.
I don't know what to expect down
opposite Garth Brooks in this interview.
I want her and what he would tell me how
hard it would be to get him to discuss
his horrific crimes. What I found
was that he was very forthcoming.
He volunteered details that
may be difficult to hear.
I began by asking what he wanted
from the men he picked up.
Yeah.
It's hard to comment on anything
they do because if you do that,
then you got to comment on the fact that
yes, you do have three arms. I mean,
just don't want to show the other one.
That's why you count them.
I'm the last guy that wants to see it
over. The greatest part is the fun of it.
Good. Um, you know, your time
comes when your time goes. It
was two years ago in this apartment
in Milwaukee,
police discovered the grizzly remnants
of one of the most horrible crime sprees
in American history.
Confessed that he had seduced,
murdered and dismembered 17 young men.
He even ate some of his victim's body
parts. That was not my first choice.
Basically, I wanted somebody that was
thin and beautiful and lots of hair.
There it is. Wow. We knew
it. We knew it all along.
It's surprising, but not surprising. Not
Surprising. He is a deadly psychopathic.
Of course.
Who made that one magnum meme
one I think nagged a meme.
I don't know if the one is there. Look,
look for me. Yeah. Wow. Great job.
Exposing the truth, but
a psycho, that guy is,
he really has killed a lot
of people. Kid Ness. Um,
that was so funny. Yeah.
No, it's just no one. It's a
magnum underscore me. My, okay.
My Instagram again,
I'll be reposting all the ones that
roll in because I posted the initial,
one of his horrible cvs and then I
requested people make their own and remix
them. We can't often play
it all because of the song,
but I can post them on social.
So here you go.
God Damn God damn be posting
Tom's horrific hair, hair pics.
I did a good job. No, I did a good job.
How are we going? How are we going
to fill this big old, big old arena?
You know some people aren't so happy that
we tease Garth. Did you know that? Oh,
I bet. I bet. Kind of upset. Okay,
well,
well sometimes Sagora right?
Vernon Brooks to third of the Garth
called me up last night was talking shit.
You speak fucking funny man.
Messing with our ticket sales.
Well, Tom Jagger ruined your
wife, Christina passage and
I'm going to tell you right now,
I've got a jar of peanut butter bag
full of broken glass. I'm a duck,
my knuckles. Then finally time
second, look at me. I'm shaking.
I'm so pissed off right now. I've
got Kim, don't tell me how tank.
I've got to get this dumb bitch time.
Sandra miss with my uncle.
He left two tickets sales last week.
Tickets up down.
Ain't nobody coming to the big
ass mother fucker stadium tour.
The town stagger keeps on running
his mouth. People are getting,
so I'm going tell you one time time.
Sagora you won't meet me a dark alley
or you could close your mouth about my
uncle Garth.
He's a good man with trees are so
sad and got a lot of fucking money.
Piss me off. No more tabs. Sagora
come on over pissing my mouth.
Try it out, mother fucker.
This guys familiar.
He's the same guy that did Billy.
Good Morning Juliet
and he was all battered
up and ray, the black guys related
to Garth. But he's right. No,
this is Garth's cousin. Yeah,
that's pretty wild. Dam. Yeah. Sad.
Gra. Yeah. This is so bananas.
What do you think people love so
much about Garth Brooks? What is it?
He must be just, it must be just
dynamite fucking shows. I have to be,
I've heard people say that the live,
the live shows amazing. They, oh,
well you have to like the music
first by country, right. His country.
And then I see that he has a girls and
like cheerleading outfits and they're
shooting off guns of
stuff in that CBS train.
That's cheerleaders probably cause
it's at Notre Dame stadium. Oh, right.
So I imagine that's part of the fun. Yeah.
Probably special for that. But I mean,
generally speaking,
he just puts on a crazy show.
He sells out more than like lady
Gaga. Uh, that's a good question.
I Dunno. I really don't know. I mean,
I know the weirdest thing to me is that
he's huge in Ireland. That's bizarre.
Like huge. Yeah. He's, he's
so fucking famous over there.
I'm like Ireland. Really. I don't, I
don't get it. Lady Gaga is, you know,
definitely international superstars. So
who knows. But there definitely both.
Monsters
gave me so much joy is the
weird his weirdness. Uh, last
week, you know, we had the,
um,
the guy who told you that, like, you,
you make my eyes a telescope.
Yeah. Yeah. The homeless guy.
He wasn't homeless. The horsey it,
what are you talking about? Hey,
that guy's not normal. What?
No. Why would you say that?
Because he looks homeless. What's,
no, he's definitely homeless. Tommy.
I think I was not home.
He's like a doctor or something.
I don't know if he was a
doctor, a lawyer, a lawyer.
Was it last week or was
it the week before? Uh,
it's been the council for you remember
this guy? He's my now he's super weird.
You, uh, yeah.
Uh Huh.
Because honestly,
there's really nothing that compares a
black dude spitting game. Like they're,
they're the ultimate, right.
Well, for sure. Puerto Ricans to,
yeah. I don't know. I think, I think
brothers were the number one. So Geez,
we have a segment now,
this black dude spitting game.
Right.
So,
so, um, because it's just, there's
so many great videos of this.
I haven't seen this yet, just so you
know, a lot of times, a lot of times,
neither one of us has seen we're,
we're seeing it the first
time you're seeing it.
So I think some people think
that like there are times, yeah,
there are times where I'll see a and that
I just want to like surprise you with
it. But most of the time I haven't seen
the videos and just let me be clear here.
You're running under the assumption that
it's black guys who spent the most of a
folder for me. Oh. And
it just says that, well,
it doesn't say that black guys usually
split the most game saying that this is a
video about that. Oh, Gotcha. Okay.
Claiming racially that they had the
best game. Well that is what I'm saying.
The video that I'm hoping supports that.
I'll see it.
Another thing to point out quickly,
stop fucking sending videos that
you want on the show to anywhere,
but the email address. Oh,
right. I'm not going to open it.
I don't watch them on Instagram.
If you sent it to me on Facebook,
if you send it to me on Twitter. No,
that's why we have an email address.
We have a producer that reads
these and watches these.
So if you want it to play on the show,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com there's
no house in that email address.
Send it to my personal email to stuff
for the show. We don't play it. I don't,
you know,
I think one out of 50 of those will make
it like a half to happen to open it and
want it to move it forward. Just send it
to him if he wanted to play on the show.
All right,
here you go.
[inaudible]
well I will say this, that doesn't
necessarily support what I was going for.
A this guy is like mouth to mouth really
close and the cording himself kind of
whispering or singing I will
say doesn't have the best teeth.
Um, and which kind of is a
distraction about it cause he,
oh he has them but there's
like they're not all there one.
The ones that are there like candy,
corn
cousin.
But I love you.
Okay. A couple of things.
This is not spitting game.
This dude is just singing along to a song.
He has four teeth,
three are a different color, top teeth.
So he might have some more bottom you. Um,
but she's really into it. She
is really, she really digs it.
Summarize cares what we think. Exactly.
Smell. He thinks he's the best.
They can't smell good. That mouth. Can't
Smith's a bad mouth. That is a bad mouth.
But are you, are you really objecting to
the blanket statement? Black dudes spit.
Here's the deal and here's,
here's why.
I'm just wanting to challenge it a
little bit cause I feel like Puerto Rican
guys are up there too.
Where you think they got it from pro?
The black guys of course. Okay. You think
they train has seminars and they train.
It wasn't a seminar. Just they
just picked up on it. Black.
There's definitely split the most game.
Yeah, of course. That's true. Yeah.
Because here's the difference.
I find that like when I was a single lady,
like I'd be walking through a parking
lot just at like the grocery store. Yeah.
And a black dude would yell at me from
like across the parking lot like sub girl
and like what's our bread or whatever.
I got I red red hair or
whatever your hair color is.
That's how they would yell at him.
Sure.
And then they start talk talking shit
like how you know across a parking lot the
Latino guy might,
Latino guy might actually want to be
face to face interaction different degree
later. Yeah. Of Skill. Just
like in any sport. Yeah.
I mean the guy that yelled, hey
red, he might be an amateur. Right.
Or you put a professional in front of
you. Sure you pay. These are coming off.
Sure. Okay. Oh Shit.
Ah.
Oh God.
His mouth is so bad.
There's like there's also rotten parts.
Yeah.
He has like dump gum decay and
Ah, ah. It can't smell good.
God,
she loves it.
She really loves him a lot and he really,
really ruined my pitch. I thought we were
going to listen to someone being like,
I turned it to a telescope again.
Like that car
man.
Darn it. Turn it to a telescope.
You melt me every day.
Yeah. Fuck dammit.
I've been looking at your picture.
So low weight.
Yeah. That dude that dude has got
Todd this mouth thing is really,
I don't like it.
That mouth.
Who? The fucking blue band.
Why would you, ah, God mean.
Yeah. That's pretty nice. That guy needs
dental surgery to yesterday. Yeah, Bro.
Dm it.
So upsetting.
Speaking of upsetting,
we were watching the Shahs of sunset
last night on our bravo. Whoa.
Yeah.
Catching up.
We have a lot of our favorite word
catching up on and you got so upset.
It was a Mercedes was
getting married and the,
I haven't seen you this upset a lot.
One of March.
You were like, I'm so upset
right now. I'm so upset.
What about her wedding upset you the most?
Um,
I dunno,
I guess I,
I guess in my core I like certain
levels of respect for certain events.
Yeah. You so like, I mean they even
commented on one aspect of it during it,
she's walking down the aisle,
she stopped walking down the aisle to s
shake hands with people and say thanks
for coming. Like as she's walking down
the aisle until I was watching, I'm like,
what are you doing? She was
drunk. They were, they're both so,
and then, uh, like she was
like, oh my God. And she's like,
I can't believe you're here and
hey, you came to this, oh my God.
And like walked down the aisle.
That's for after the right.
So she's plastered that. I just
started to cringe at, I was like, Ooh.
Then it's their wedding. It's
like this beautiful setup, right?
I mean, yeah. Lovely decorations.
And then the officiant officiant says,
you know, whatever he says, and
then he's like, will you take her?
And the guy's like, apps
a Fuckin lutely, you know?
Do you want that for your wedding too? I
don't know. To me, I mean, these aren't,
it wasn't a punk rock wedding. It's
like black tie. It's a nice looking.
And then like what I, where I
wanted to just crawl inside myself,
I felt cringey or than watching
my own audition was a, the vows,
the vows exchanged.
They didn't right and advanced.
Now he said something like
pretty like decent, you know,
for his mouth. I'm not criticizing
the, you know, the writing of it. Um,
like she kind of cut
them off at one point,
but he got out a nice thing and then she
bombed so hard and she started talking
to other people and was like, don't look
over there. Okay. Do you not want valves?
Okay, I'm not going to do vows that like
during the week I was like, I hate this.
It made me so uncomfortable.
It made me upset because it feels like
a disrespect of not only the event but
like of the people there and showed up
to come to your wedding, the whole thing.
The whole thing made me, I think you and
I are traditionalist in that sense. Yeah.
I personally,
and this is just me like I believe in
wearing closed toe shoes to your own
wedding. To your wedding. Okay.
Instead of like flip flops.
I know sometimes people wear flip flops.
Well,
a beach wedding you got to
where I'm at the beach wedding.
Let's just say we've attended
a ceremony where, Oh yeah,
that was nowhere near a beach.
That was weird. That's weird. Yeah.
We weren't even close to it be.
It was an indoor daytime affair.
However everyone else,
I would say that the,
the audience was dressed more
dress better than the groom.
He was wearing flip flops.
That was weird.
Flip flops are basically
not for most situations.
Correct.
We know they're the ultimate leisure wear.
It's great if you want to wear them
to run errands or go to the beach,
obviously listen, even
as a city dweller. Yeah.
I don't really like wearing flip flops
in the streets. Do you know what I mean?
Yeah.
I'm
a little even like, it's a lot of shit
out there. There's no holes and shit.
You're in Hollywood.
You're like,
I got to tell you the grossest
is a flip flops in New York City.
When you see people like
Hollywood basically walking
the streets and you're like,
dude, this shit is nasty. Like there's
fucking plague on the ground. Pretty much.
But how do you know what I'm saying?
Like have some respects.
It's your one wedding dance.
Fuck, it's a desert. Sure.
But it's still like the
streets are nasty bro.
Line to vomit and garbage
and you're walking around
pretty much barefoot almost.
There's a very thin barrier.
Yeah.
I think you and I are are traditionalist
when it comes to those types of things.
I don't, I don't like being too
irreverent on solemn occasions,
like marriage, baptisms, things
of that nature. Have some respect.
Who told me about somebody thinks that
I'm crazy at a funeral too. Oh yeah, no,
we read it on this show.
We write it on the show.
It was a while back where somebody
wrote in how they said that um,
as they were lowering a casket of a
family member that the grandmother has her
phone and was like, I dunno, like
around two I could be there. Yeah.
Sandwiches are like just took a while.
Calls during the funeral.
No. What do you fucking do me have
some respect? I guess that's my thing.
I have a little fucking respect.
Oh my God. Speaking of respect,
I have two incidences.
I what the star,
but I was at the Starbucks on my way
home from man Diego and there was a chick
watching a video, full volume, full
volume, just sitting at a table,
a young 20 somethings
like lack of respect.
Nobody wants to hear your crazy video.
Secondly,
there was only one bathroom
at the Starbucks and I
just don't believe in going
in there and posting up
and taking a huge shit.
When you know that there's one bathroom
for the entire Starbucks population,
it's not fair to do that because there's
a line that forms and then you know
like you would on an airplane, there's
two bathrooms sometimes front and back,
so was like, okay, some guys shouldn't be
here. It is shit fuel. That's what it is.
All it is,
it's bowel and and urine maker.
Yeah,
it's bowel torture and bladder torture
and then they only give you one toilet to
rotate at all code code.
Do you know the code?
I got to shit right now the
code is nine one one bitch,
I've got to go down and then
they're like, ah, the coat today.
Today it's a, it's one
one. It's one eight,
one six I should be try it. Try. Yeah. And
you're like, Oh God, you got to put pound.
I think before you do you pound first
one you're shaking and sweating trying to
take a shit. But what I'm saying
is, look, if you got to shit,
you get in to Starbucks right
quick, quick, quick, and then out.
But I'm talking like this fool posted up.
You know what I'm saying?
And there's a 10 minutes of a shit. Don't
do your 10 minutes shit. Oh, I know.
There's a lot of people that
just abuse that. Are you crazy?
I think they just do an
email. Yeah. And He, you know,
people are waiting asshole and they really
got to shit. They really got to shit.
Yeah.
I got to shit and piss now.
Second place is we were
interviewing for a babysitter man.
Farting loudly. Yeah. Anyways,
so what I do is I interview people and
I let them hang out with the kid with me
around supervising and see how they jive.
So this person was in our home,
may be a couple of hours and I come inside
from being outside and she opens the
bathroom door and this, this flushing
sound and she says to me, Oh,
do you have a spray?
And I see the I,
the smell hits me and I'm like,
this bitch took a shit in my house.
Hey,
one minute one bro. Bold, bold, bold.
You can't just go to like a potential
employers house. I got to shit right now.
Right now. No. How are you going to bring
you to shit right before you got here?
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah. You don't shit day like
right away. Minute one at my,
you have a right to shit obviously, but
you know. Well I don't even know you.
It's a, it's a bold choice cause you're
not going to hold your shit in, you know,
but no, but I didn't fucking
bring your own spray Jesus.
Or I guess I just don't think you
should have this amazing spray shit and
someone's fucking house
that you don't know.
I ordered a spray that you're going
to flip out. Yeah, it's amazing.
The headed at the gym. Okay. I say the
best spray. It's a shit spray. Well yeah,
yeah. But it's like, it's not what you
think is not one of those big error.
So it's just like a, yeah, the smell is,
so the thing is we have another
bathroom that has those sprays. Yeah.
There is a bathroom that contains those
fucking know when to shit and when to
keep your ass hole closed dude.
Or at least courtesy flush that the
smell doesn't. And it was nasty.
Like she really, she
said, oh she really shit.
Aw, it's so nasty. Oh No, she's
not going to work here. Yeah,
I know. Crazy down. Are you
shitting someone's house?
You don't even fucking know them yet.
Yeah. That's Kinda wild. Um, look,
the phenomena has also just exploded
for us reviving this a good morning.
Julia has just been such an amazing thing.
Um, and everyone's getting
involved. I can say that,
um,
people that you don't expect,
and I want to give credit because
we've made mention of this before,
that you know,
a lot of dudes are usually the ones that
do to send in a lot of their things.
You know, it's a lot. It's a lot of guys.
But the ladies they came through on,
right. Let's see some lady,
Julia's ladies want to Julia.
So here is lacy
Juliette.
Hi.
This car here that I'm driving.
Yeah,
I built it myself eating that he
didn't work when I got the car,
but it's like I'm really
handy so I was able to fix it.
What else do am I really good at? Oh,
fucking a lot of makeup. All comments.
You know what I mean?
Five Times minimum.
Think about it.
Oh,
I realize too that there's,
there's gotta be no one that understands
the creepiness of Joe's thing more than
women. Of course, you guys are the ones
that get bombarded by the guy who's like,
I know how to fuck.
I want to be with you no matter what.
Yeah, it's, it's really never
welcome. And here's the thing,
the guy that you do want to date, it's
never that guy telling you that stuff.
Right. It's always the creeper who
you're trying to, the guy that you do,
you wish would say that to you,
like probably you're not sure if he's
going to call, you know? But yeah,
just a regular, yeah, he's, it's never,
it's never a wanted thing generally.
Of course. Let me tell you a crazy
shit like that. And what's this here
chose sex life. You know, he's
really great guy.
He taught me a lot about ventilation.
One Hansen,
he damaged his right hand in a fight
with my first husband. But you know what?
I had to deal with insurance
money out of the past.
You don't need to know about that shit
anyway. So I think you should try him out.
I think you should go full throttle.
I think that um,
one thing about him is SOM Yukata
make sure he takes his meds on.
So that's one thing.
He's a guy of his pure heart,
but you got to make sure he takes his
valley. I'm and as valid tracks in a,
and if he's not, he just give it to them
on a piece of cheese. He'll never know
the difference. But I really think
the two of you should go full.
Trotta I really do. You
both like gyms, you know,
I hear you both. They both have
a lot of similarities and dumb.
You know, I think you
should do it. Okay. So
get him the fuck out my life. Go
for this. I just need to move on.
You know what?
I love the
fuck out of my life.
No, she did. No kidding.
A lot of friends.
He built that place.
One handed here is Rebecca.
Good morning. Julia was me.
Joe Ley, you know that meeting you
yesterday. It's the best day of my,
you're still beautiful
flower.
I know it was. Might be a little
hard to hear for you right now, but
I'm making a video.
You know what she really nails is the
intensity because he's so overwhelmed.
She was like doing the thing
which you solve. Rom saying it.
That's what made the eyes
closed. It's emotion. You.
I love you. That's called a grounded
performance. Yeah, I like it.
Good Morning Julia. It's me. Joe,
on my way to work here wanting
to make you a quick video.
Just tell you how gorgeous you
ask God. It's good. So gorgeous.
When I sniffed your bike,
see? Yes. Oh my God.
The fragrance took me away.
All right, I'll see you later on
him. I'm picking up for dinner.
That boyfriends that we're
going to have some problems.
Giulia announcing problems.
You don't want to mess with me
when I'm full throttle Julia.
Oh, that's good. She got the creepiness
down real aggressive to the women.
The women nailed as a
creaminess intensity. Yeah.
Yeah, you're right that
they must feel that. Oh,
we feel that and then say that they,
Gosh. Oh, here's one more from Olivia.
Good morning, Julia. I miss you so much.
I've been thinking about you every
day since I met you and I've just,
you know, I wanted to get you something,
so I got you. What dog? Julie,
guess what?
I named her that Sariah I named after you,
so anytime you're not here I can
just come out and say good morning.
Can't wait to meet you. I know she
already loves you so much, just like I do.
Right?
I love you Julie.
She nailed the psychotic lost in love,
but this is for you.
She named the dog. Keeps
saying her name. Well,
are you ready for the thing that
we've been waiting for for a while?
Finally can try to do it right now.
All right.
We have been in contact with the Giulia
from going to my God and I'm going to
try to call her right now.
Ready? I'm ready. Here we go.
I hope she,
hello.
Good afternoon,
Julia.
Hi,
how are you?
I'm great. This is Tom Segura.
I'm here with Christina P.
And. M. We are so excited, Julia.
So excited. Thank you for
taking the time to do this call.
Oh yes,
no problem.
I am. So I want to start
with one thing. First of all,
uh, you know, we didn't know that this,
when this was brought to our attention,
we didn't know that it was like a thing
and then it kind of faded away and it
was brought to our attention.
Again,
we've been mesmerized by it and there's
so many different stories about the
origin of,
of you getting this video,
a message on your phone. People
said, you know, it was a bar.
It was a parking lot.
It was the gym.
Can you tell us how this
actually came about?
Yeah. So this took place actually it
was about three years ago. Was it?
2015. Okay. Um, I was going
to the gym, not to work out,
but to Chan and I'm at planet fitness.
One of the things you have
to do is you sign in. Okay.
So I go and I sign in, 15
minutes goes by, you know,
I walk out and it's pitch black out.
I'm walking to my car to here,
my name's Julia Julia.
I turned around and like with the house.
So I started kind of walking slowly
back over to this voice I heard.
And as I reach this man,
he's older,
I'm probably 20 years older
than me. I'm kind of like,
all right. And he's like, oh,
Julia. And I was just like, yeah,
do I know you and you my hand
him the maybe you know a friend,
someone who works there, I
have no idea. So he goes, oh,
I thought you were really
beautiful and I had to talk to you.
I looked at the sign in sheet and I had
to wait till you came out just to say
hello. So I'm standing
there like, oh my God,
no wonder the bargain. I like terrified.
And I'm just like, okay, let's, you know,
let's get this going. [inaudible] you
know, he's like, oh, you know, can I,
can I take you out for
dinner or drinks some?
At the time I was still kind of talking
to an ex boyfriend and I was like,
listen, you know, I'm still talking to
my ass. I'm hoping something works out.
Um,
so probably not
as you're saying that to him though,
you're basically just trying to like
ease this guy down. You're like, ah,
I'm talking to me.
Like you're trying to be sorta diplomatic
to let them know that, you know,
I'm not trying to be rude, but I'm not
interested. Right. It sounds like that.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
You mean things that normal human beings
pick up on? I got it. Okay. Keep going.
Okay. Um, so he's saying,
Oh, you know, let me,
let me get your number. So my phone's
in my hands. I'm kind of just like,
all right, you know, I
don't know what to do.
So I just kind of handed him thinking,
let me get his number so
then he doesn't have mine.
Oh,
okay.
Me. So instead of just putting his
number and he called with my phone,
his phone,
uh,
Joe's no newbies.
Yup.
I'm driving to work and I get a check
and I'm looking, I said, you know,
who the hell is this that there are
no tax. It's just a video message.
I opened that video and I am mortified.
It's six 30 in the morning.
I'm like, what the hell?
So I didn't tell him, I didn't tell
anyone. So I had, um, at the time,
three girl roommates,
I told no one for about a week and a half,
two weeks. Cause I was just like, oh
my God, I can't believe this happened.
So I get another video a few days later.
The car one car one
the car, the bar one. Yeah.
This is like my flower.
Yes, yes. I respond and I said, Oh,
you know, ha ha, you know,
still not interested.
Um, so little mold. I ended up
telling my friends when that,
when we're drinking and I'm just like,
and you show you guys something really
freaked me out and they're like,
oh my God, this is hilarious.
You just did. On the Internet.
I'm like, dateline, like I
don't want to go missing.
And they're just like, no, no. I'm like,
he's like my dad's age and I'm
just like, you know, I feel bad.
I don't want an embarrassing
one time goodbye.
My friends share with other
people. So I started, you know,
everyone just made a joke at him. I got
flip videos from my friends, you know,
people text me. Good morning, Julia. Um,
still a year,
a year ago is by,
and I get a text from one of my friends
and I don't have Twitter, but she does.
And she goes, someone's
talking posted your video on
Twitter. And I was just like,
no way. I was like, no way.
So that's how that whole girl who
went to the bar in Chicago methods,
creepy guy named Joe. Uh,
how's that rumor got started?
So my roommate and she was like, I'm
getting, I'm going to tell everyone,
I'm just like, okay, I don't care. Do
whatever you gotta do. Um, whatever.
So video dies down again
until you guys can't,
I have no idea who sent it to you.
And the other day,
one of your band messaged me,
not sure how they got my Instagram message
either they're just like, you know,
we found you and uh,
you know,
I think you should get to the bottom
of it and you should call them.
And I was just like, you know what,
why not? It's been three years.
The real story out there.
Have you seen,
have you seen the fans?
Have you seen the fans making
their versions? Good morning, Julia
videos?
Oh my God, yes. Are
hilarious. Yes. And there's,
we just got through playing six more
that were submitted all by women.
So it's a women's women's versions of
it and it's really hilarious. I mean,
so
right
now back to the, to the,
so this guy you, oh,
so you told him like,
oh my ex and I bobbled so that's
why he was bringing that up.
Did anything ever come about?
Like did you ever run into him
again at the gym or anywhere else?
Um, I stopped going to the
gym shortly after that.
They didn't want to run into him, so
I ended up switching jam. Oh yeah.
My, yeah. But I did find out,
one of my friends was like, you know,
I'm curious if you has a Facebook.
So we took his number,
we put it into Facebook and its profile
showed up and she goes, oh my God,
I went to high school with his
kid. Oh, he's about, I'm, yeah.
So I'm 28 hours to about
25 at the time she was 19
she was, wait, she was in
high school with his kid.
No kid is a kid. Yeah.
With his kid. Oh my God.
But he's 20 years older than Eylea that.
Yeah.
Gotcha. Yeah, no worries. Yeah. So he's
definitely a little bit, yeah, exactly.
Now, most importantly, Juliet,
did you ever have him do the
crown molding in your house?
The ceiling fans?
Do you like it?
You know,
I have some ceiling fans in my closet
right now that I need to be put up,
so I might give him a call.
The funny, you know, I gotta say
it's like it is, you know, I,
there's things to laugh at it in the
video. Obviously it's so ridiculous.
But then I do kind of feel badly for him
because I see how desperately it's um,
you know, it's unnatural to express that
level of love for somebody you just met,
but he's just mesmerized by it.
Mentally ill psychotic.
Yeah. It's psychotic.
I'm not, I'm, I'm not your Noah,
you're going no, no. You Go Juliet.
No, not really quite. I'm not quite sure.
I'm not really quite sure cause it's
not like it was like a good day that I'm
out of like out at the bar.
Like I was literally hair up looking
like a mess coming from canning.
Yeah. I tried it. Two guys a compliment.
But I mean he knew what he was doing
because at the end of the video when you
study,
I hope this video didn't scare you.
Yes, that's right. Yes.
He always stood out to us.
He knows. And I'll tell you what's
really great about this, Julia,
is that because we've exposed this
guy for a creeper, it's not fair.
First of all, yes, we
have empathy for him.
But it's not fair that you've had to
change your life and your routine,
you a different gym and all.
Yeah,
because this guy doesn't know
how to fucking reign it in.
And he's so he's an adult. He
has, yeah. A kid is his kid,
by the way, a girl. Is it a daughter?
Um, I think he has two.
From what I remember.
I think he has two twins. I think
one's a boy, one's a girl or boy,
I'm not quite sure.
Well good. So he's a great
example for both. Not quite sure.
I know that when our sons,
when our son's reached a certain age,
I will play that video and be like,
don't ever do this to a girl. Okay.
Um,
yeah.
But I would encourage all the women
listening to send us your videos of guys
being creepy because this shit needs to
stop. It's not fair that she has no fair.
No, it's not scares. It's not
course. No, it's not cool at all.
Know. I always found it like as
people were before the store again,
people were like hating
on, you know, hating on me.
And it wasn't even me who supposed
and they're just like, oh,
she would have been younger or the guy
would have been is the guy would have
been younger and you know,
like more her type.
Then she would have loved it and
I always disagreed with that.
I can't stand to come up to me at the
bar and it doesn't matter the age or who
were you is I think it was that.
That's too much.
I'm giving them the exact same
reaction that I would give Joe.
It's not that he's older than I am
and why, you know, it's a big deal.
It was just creepy,
creepy and it was just too much.
His game is all so fun.
Hey, now I wish, I wish someone
would build, build me a house now.
Yeah. I mean the thing is
too, it's like there's a,
we were just talking about the fact that
the person that you want to send their
love video is never the person that's
like, you know what I mean? Like,
if you saw like whatever the
hottest guy ever is to you,
he's never going to send you a video like
that. That's the guy who, who you never,
you know, he probably doesn't
call cause it's just out of it
now. What about dating now Julia,
are you, are you a single lady?
Good.
I'm actually wanting to get back together,
you know,
that's over with.
And what is your sense of, uh,
what is your current boyfriend?
Think of all this nonsense as he amused
by it. I'm amused by Joe or what?
Oh Man.
When I first,
just so he's been around probably two
and a half of the three years I've been
going on. He thought it was hilarious
when we first found out and he,
he didn't know what he always said.
He's like, Oh yeah, you know, go,
go talk on a show about
a few different places.
And I was just like, ah, I
don't know. I don't know.
So what I told him that you guys,
he's like, yeah, just do it. Do it.
Would you say that,
would you say that you and your current
are going full throttle or are you guys
kind of like,
you know,
okay.
You know,
I shouldn't embarrass them,
but I'd like if we went full
throttle a little more. Ah,
wait till he finds out, we better
get on it before you get more videos.
So can I ask you to where,
where is it, where is Joe from?
Where is this region? I mean,
give us the general region.
East Coast,
east coast. I would say jersey.
I'm thinking he's north. Central.
North. Central East. Okay. He's
Darya. Okay. We don't want to give it,
you give it four days.
I know. I don't want,
I don't need gym now.
No, no, no, no, no, no. But, uh,
okay. That's about right. Yeah,
that's about right. Well
look, I gotta tell you, oh,
go ahead. Go ahead. Go ahead.
Yeah,
yeah, I was gonna say, I think
it's acting kind of gives it away.
Yeah, yeah. Just making sure.
Yeah. Wow. Um, yeah, it's,
it's not Birmingham, Alabama.
Um, but look, Julia,
we so appreciate you calling in,
uh,
giving us the real story.
Putting the bed, the rumors,
letting us know how this really happened.
We're huge fans of yours and
have this amazing video that, uh,
I'm sure at moments terrified you.
But thankfully we can all have
a good laugh at it now. Um,
thanks for taking your time. Anything
else you want to add, Christina? No,
I'm just a, I'm happy that you're going
full throttle with a new man, a new man.
Factful and a, I'm sorry that that
happened to you. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're sorry on behalf of them. Hell man.
I'm sorry that happened to you, but I'm,
uh, I'm glad that you survived and we
can have some fun with it now. Yeah.
Okay.
Oh yeah, no, definitely
not. I mean, like I said,
it cracks me up all these
videos I keep saying and yeah,
I like when I'm driving to
work and I'm like miserable,
like waking up or I just kind of like
listening to, I'm getting a good laugh,
so it starts my day off.
Wow.
Great. Well listen to this, uh,
to this episode because it has,
like I said, uh, all women doing
their good morning, Julia as in,
it's pretty amazing.
Oh,
that's awesome.
All right. Thanks so much Julia.
Take care. Good bye Julia.
Hi.
There you go.
Me a you. Yes ma'am. You on
the phone was the greatest.
I'm going to start taxing her
all the time. Come on. And Julia,
do you think her friends just
do that relent? Lovely whores.
I would never let it end. Like it hasn't
stopped in three years. They started,
they probably started to fade and
then when this came back they're like,
it's odd. They were like, I was
waiting for this to come back. Well,
cause we've been saying it to each other
when we wake up in the morning. Oh yeah.
That's how I get to that baby. Julian,
when I'm on the road every morning I say,
good morning Julia from you. Will
you text me every morning? My flower,
my everything.
Um, all right, well we have uh, some
more stuff lined up. Let's, uh, let's,
let's grab our boy here and get this
going. This is so fun. All right.
That was such an amazing call with the
real Julia from Good Morning Julia and do
two unbelievable demand and requests.
We did it.
Um,
it's up in the store now.
There are less go full throttle and good
morning Julia shirts with ceiling fans.
And here's what we did,
both men's and women's guts.
A lot of women have asked for, uh, some
of the shorts to be in women's cuts.
So we did it. Uh, there's black,
let's go full throttle and there's
gray. Good Morning Julia. Of course.
Both have Joe's trademark ceiling fans.
So go to a MERC method.com/tom
Segura merge method.com.
Don't forget to do your Christmas
shopping yet this year on our store.
Why not get the genes in your life?
Yeah, Jean Jesus wore jeans. Sweater.
Yeah. And as of this recording,
by the way, I should tell
them that I haven't confirmed,
but I know that it's shipping is in route.
We,
I had these amazing posters made for the
Philly shows and there's a little bit
of overstock,
so I'm having them sent to our store.
So check back at merchant method.
I'll post it on Instagram and stuff,
but they'll go quickly.
They always go quickly.
If you were at any of the Philly shows,
are you just like the original artwork?
This one has me as a Barista killing
guy. Oh that's great. It's really funny.
So, yeah, sure. I think I've
writer dye shirts too. Don't
I? On your, yeah, you have.
Write it down.
Check that one out. It's hilarious.
It's me as a gang banger. Chola yeah,
and you can still,
it's December 4th as of this recording,
meaning you're probably hearing
this on the fifth or six. Um,
you could still get some of that Christmas
stuff probably in time for Christmas
if you order now. There's the
Jesus wore jeans, um, sweater,
t shirt and then there's the
Santa wears jeans hat and these,
there's our ornament bunch too
in the stocking and the ornament.
I love it. And don't forget your f g
t r a t d socks. Yeah, the socks came.
Those were fantastic. Those the ride till
death. That's right. I also, I mean, look,
and don't forget your classic shirts.
A lot of times.
I see you guys wearing your a double pipe.
Classic shirts.
I see a lot of just glass and
shirts. Yeah, those are my favorites.
I love the jeans, sweatshirt. That
is always been my favorite socks.
I'm telling you. It's so nice and
soft and it just fits just right.
It's my favorite thing. You're right. I
just a and then also so many good things.
If you're a fan of your mom's house,
our, our um, Christmas bundle and then,
oh, the gene, here's my ride or die. Sure.
Guy, men's and women's and the
gene beanie gene beanie. Yeah.
I got to wear that too. What you Dork
titties in Philly. This can be risk doc,
the home here now.
And don't forget your bikes.
That's the one of the first shirts
that started this whole story.
Actually that is true, uh, bikes.
But the uh,
you know that I in there and the m o r
r rep at merchant method was like when I
opened the file that said
Piss on me and she goes,
I was certain that it would not sell.
I really thought you'd lost your mind.
And then it's sold out. It's on
me and beat me. And I go, I go,
we have a really amazing fan base.
She goes, yeah, yeah. She goes, yeah,
I saw a piss on me and I go, this,
this to me, that shirt go down.
It's done. Oh, that one. This one. Wait.
But that there's also one with just the,
the word that's your face with your
mouth open as if to say piss in my mouth.
I know. Let's try it out. Try it
out. These are four strokes. Yeah.
There's the motor for stroke and
the golf for stroke. Yup. Yeah,
just glass and water channel,
but also tea RTD. And,
and why am age black Hoodie zip
up standard. That's ball hog. Yes.
Here's the um, oh yeah. See, look, look
at the socks. Yeah. So that's on me.
So suddenly she goes, I the piss
on me socks came in. I was like,
he's not going to sell these sold out
blessing in disguise shirt from my first
special. These, we'll see. Yeah, this
is great. I'm making fitness. Yeah,
it was the women's one sold so many
great, great things. We have in the store.
So many great tee shirts from this
show. Surprise your loved one. Um,
we'll look last time,
last time about some of the dark webs,
most disturbing pornography.
And this time we're going to learn more.
I have with us a friend, a great
comedian. You may have seen him,
um, on the road by himself or
you may have seen him with me.
He's come with me out in a
lot of shows in the last tour.
We will be together coming up in I think.
Is it San Francisco?
San Francisco is coming up.
It is the great and Hilarious Josh Pod.
Yeah.
Hi.
It's this one then.
That's just the Joshes trademarks out.
So a woman crying.
Yeah.
So Josh introduced last fall to a segment
that we like to call the dark web.
Okay.
Hello everyone.
How are you?
Josh? Is the authority on all
things darkness? It is webs.
Josh has really great at this
stuff. Um, I've always, you know,
I've had the, uh, the, the, the
conversations with him about,
you know,
all this crazy stuff on tour and I knew
we were kindred spirits when we would
connect, talking about weird
things. Sure. Fun Things.
But he really knows this stuff,
you know, he does and yeah,
I try diaper it talks
about that diaper last time
and we learned about and word porn.
It was great. Anyway. Oh yeah. Um,
go back and get that one to listen if
you haven't heard of that one and look up
last time Josh was here, so this
time gene, I said, Josh, let's go.
Let's do a deep dive.
Last time it was pornography.
What have you got for me this time?
I'll let him introduce it. Josh,
what are we talking about?
Well, I thought this would be sort of
a public service for you, Christina.
You think Tom's going to murder you?
Probably at some point.
That's like a possibility.
Yes.
Well today we can compare him to some
past serial killers and we can see some
similarities. Perhaps. Maybe
some differences. Maybe you'll be
maybe some differences.
Maybe you know,
a few hearing that maybe you'll
be calmed after this, like, oh,
I'm not going to get murdered.
Right. Thanks. I appreciate
it. This Josh. No problem.
Um, Josh, who should I pull up first?
Well,
I brought three cases with me today.
Maybe you're familiar with some of them.
Maybe you're not.
I wait, honestly, only
one of the, well, sorry,
one of the names is vaguely familiar and
then one of the monikers I'm familiar
with. Okay. So you're
pretty well versed already.
I thought it was pulling some obscure.
It's still, I don't know a lot about this.
Well, let's start with good
old. This is recent, by the way.
Robert Pickton Aka the pig farmer killer.
God a k a pork chop.
Rob.
Well, he has the same beard shaving
technique that my husband does.
That's a similarity. That
haircut too. I probably could,
this front is pretty much gone. I could
grow the back out. Ever think about that.
Um, I don't know. That's kind of an
interesting look. I will say, um,
from this profile, it's a, you know,
not the worst looking guy. I mean,
he's not the most handsome man.
There are women, almost a hundred
that would agree with you.
Holy Shit. That many, well,
pork chop rob here. Uh, would you
guess that he's a millionaire?
He really, he's a millionaire from
which is the most fascinating farming.
Well, yes, it's from owning a farm.
His parents had owned this farm for a
hundred years and they bought it for 13
grand in like 1963 and then in 1994,
he's found out the farm was worth
seven point $2 million on my life.
So he sold portions of it here
and there every couple of years.
Keep that fund verse some millions
of dollars. And needless to say,
the farming went to shit.
They weren't really doing that anymore,
but he still had a lot
of hogs on the farm,
including a 600 pound boar that
would like patrol the farm and,
and bite and things.
Did he put his talents into another
field when it wasn't farming?
Did He do other things?
In fact, he did. He uh,
made a non for profit organization out
of his farm called the piggy palace.
Good Times place.
And it was a society that would hold
events and parties for organizations so
that,
that farm of his became a party zone.
Can I pull up this farm? Yes, of course.
Yes. This is what the farm looked like.
Very vast.
That barn right there held many of
parties for vagrants and sex workers and
hell's angels.
Lots of cool rad people were
partying with the piggy palace boys
and our man here. Uh, was it the pork,
the pork man porkchop
rob door, chuck Robb. Um,
his target though was lady.
Yes. Ladies of the night sex
workers in particular. Oh. And uh,
when you would hold these parties,
of course it would attract those people.
They'd come and do drugs and drink and
then he would rape and murder them.
Subsequently you,
yeah.
So eventually one of the workers of
the farm kind of noticed, you know,
all these women that are coming
around here seem to go missing.
So something's up. And uh, eventually, uh,
an investigation was held.
This investigation was so thorough.
They called it the ground zero of Canada.
Why?
Because they had to bring in
heavy machinery, excavators,
things of that nature so that they could
find human remains and they hadn't had
an undertaking quite like that since
Ground Zero in nine 11 oh my God.
Because there were very few
remains left DC. What rob did,
the reason he is the pork shop king is
because he would feed the women and their
remains to the pigs.
Okay.
And then he would take the pigs and
make bacon and things and sell it to the
public.
Oh my God.
Did you know about this? Tom?
Why are you laughing? Psycho?
Pretty crazy. Yeah. There was a name
or who is like,
I bought Bacon from that guy all the
time and now he has to live with himself
that he aid basically. Yeah, a lady.
It could you imagine just
going about your day.
Wow. So he might kill and dismember
and then feed that to the pigs.
Right. And then tailor the Higgs
and make Bacon and yes, I really,
great way to get rid of evidence.
A brilliant, right. I mean,
I mean he's a millionaire. Yes. The thing
is, that's a good thing about capitalism.
You can always exploit
something to your advantage.
We've talked about this forever.
What's the best way to dispose of a body?
And I think we found it now feeding
it to the pigs and then selling,
well we have some clubs
they can. So they convicted him
of 27 murders. That's a lot,
right in this clip
he adds to the number a little bit.
So this is, uh, this is him in, he's
already in, in a jail cell in a, in uh,
his cellmate has been undercover for
months embedding himself in order to get a
confession out of him.
Cause like I said,
this investigation at the farm so thorough
and also not really raising a lot of
answers. They're spending millions
of dollars to investigate.
And so they need to this guy to
get a confession. That's really,
are you really all the
darkest motherfucker? I know
how much knowledge you have.
Let's, let's, uh, let's
watch these cloves. Tell me
what's going on here. Okay.
Yeah.
Well it's kind of inaudible there, but
just saying that he's, that he got sloppy.
Yes, he got sloppy at the end and he's
lamenting in that fact. He's saying,
you know, I, if I woulda
kept my shit right and tight,
I would have fucking murdered
more bitches, you know? Yeah.
And the officer is saying, oh, but it's
just like, oh, that's fucked up and stuff,
you know? Yeah. He's not doing
a real good job. The officer.
Okay.
Yeah. Do you wanted one
more? He said he couldn't,
so he confessed to 49 and you want to
add one more to make an even fig make the
big five
zero.
Yeah.
So like what was Mayweather when he
went did exactly like 49 all right.
Sound is nicest. You have to get
that 50 you get that big 50 spots.
Half a hundred yes. Gotta be a thrill to
do this. All right, here is, let's see,
there was a stop so you can
go relieve yourself of that
early 2007
Oh,
that's right, officer. It is
math. That's good math. Yeah.
They're just kind of
reconfirm. He's like, yeah man.
Fucking imagine if I had gotten
50 yeah. So he's just like, man,
I'm a real cool dude. I, I coulda
got 50 trying to talk to the officer.
Like he's one of his,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's a theme that will carry on
through all this, by the way,
is injecting women with, I didn't, I, you
know, you wonder how do they kill him?
Do they strangle him,
stab him and stuff?
It turns out a lot of them
were just injecting things
like antifreeze into their
veins or Windex was used. All these like
in five to 10 minutes, they're dead.
That's all it takes. And I
didn't know that. I mean, yeah,
you might want to write that one
down. Don't write that down. Damn you.
Where'd you find this footage?
This is, I didn't know that.
This is your guest is
fighting that if this footage,
you gotta read this audience,
they can't hear anything.
So he's saying, uh, the, the killer
saying another party says, yeah,
I mean all this, all, they fucking
got a lot of stuff on me. Um,
and then the officer says
no. Oh Shit. Hey. Yeah,
Canadian. That's yes. That's what, that's,
that's why it's, what is it not part of
it? I don't really know because, well,
what's happened? Like I said, he
was convicted of 27 murders. Oh.
So he's saying like that's why it's
here. He's admitting. He's like,
that's why you know, I,
I killed way more. Yeah.
But it's not part of it cause they
don't know. But I got sloppy at the end,
so they found some, uh, wow.
So now they're going after him for even
while he's dead. He got he, he died.
He's dead. He died naturally. Sure.
Yeah. But just somebody kill him. Ah,
Shit I should have, that's one part. I
didn't look it up. Hold on. Let's see.
That's tragic. High. Are you really
sad that that guy's dead time? Not Sad.
He died at 69. Hey, nice.
Say Hey and I'll have you know that a
farm is being made to a children's park
now. Yeah. Morbid thing to
do, right? He's this Christ.
Well, you know that murderer
land is discount land. Uh,
one time I had lunch with the guy
bought the Charles Manson murder house.
He ended up being a
television producer anyways.
He got it at a significant discount
because those Manson murders murders
happened there. Was he stoked that that
went down there? Yeah, I mean, not stuck,
but he was like, oh, it was
cheaper because no one wanted
to live here. I'm like,
yeah, no shit. Also, I had to change the
street address. That's terrible, Tom.
So how hard are you right now
having watched that? Well,
I'm glad there's a desk
here. I'll just say that. Um,
these next fellows,
these ones you might remember from
your childhood call one second.
I just wanted to see. Yes, we
had you so terrifying. Potter.
I'm just looking to see like
what his cause of death,
but I can't really see just evil baby.
No, I just wanted to see if there was,
if he was,
if he himself was killed.
I don't think they have
death penalty and they don't.
I meant like an inmate or
something. Oh, I see. I see.
But somebody injected him with Windex.
He probably died of some cardiovascular
thing. Eating all that pork
doesn't show that he's dead.
Oh, okay. So he's not done.
He's not that he could very well be
living. I mean this again happened,
he was put in jail 10 years. It was not
fair though. He got life in prison. Yeah.
Why is that not fair? I
mean, I mean, you know,
like why don't you give the guy a
shot to get out there and make some
rehabilitation has been saying that for
so long that the prison system does not
rehab criminals enough. It's crazy.
This guy's just a lost cause.
Yeah, he is super smart. I mean his whole
scheme was really intelligent. Right.
To set up a non for profit
to hold parties to get,
I mean good on him for
having that Shithole farm and
getting a bunch of hookers
to come hangout. That's true. I mean
he was getting laid a lot, you know,
so I mean maybe not take it
as far as murdering them,
but he was definitely getting his
date. Then again, when you murder them,
you don't have to, he's saving
money too. We didn't think about it.
He's making money. Right. Oh right, right.
It's going to feed them to the pigs.
Pork meat. Yeah. So he's getting
more out of the pig when,
when I take that away from him, um, who we
have next? Well these ones, like I said,
you might remember from your childhood
because these dudes were chilling in La.
No, no, these are the hillside
strangler and aware of them.
Look at those two. Cool. Damn it.
These guys actually they did all
their dastardly deeds here in la,
but there from where I live,
western New York, a Rochester,
New York is where they were born. So
there you go. Product of Rochester,
New York right there. That's Kenneth
Biyanki and Angelo blown. Okay.
I remember it seemed like
empty dark eyes here.
And this guy seems like he's
got a good sense of humor.
He's a real,
that guy.
I mean they're both real pieces of shit.
Yeah.
The guy on the right,
uh,
he's described as a are self described
as a world renowned car upholster.
Oh yeah.
Which is actually hate this segment or
pretty much goes with murdering people.
I mean you gotta, you gotta read a
pollster your car. So what was the,
what was there?
So they were western New York guys while
Kenneth there was getting into a lot of
trouble out in western New York and
he thought, I gotta get Outta here.
I got to find a new life.
So he hooks up with his cousin Angelo
there who lives in La and who's, uh,
a real to do out here, a real mover and
shaker, you know, real upholstering cars.
Uh, he's a a real ladies' man
apparently. And so when they arrived,
they started, you know, hanging out
together. They decide, you know,
sense Angela such a ladies' man,
why don't we prostitute women?
Oh right. Natural, make some money to
go. Yeah. So they started doing this,
you guys, exactly. These guys are
trying to make a quick buck and a,
they know how to do it and so eventually
it start pimping out women. And
uh, why, why did the sex workers
always get it? You know what I mean?
Those are nice ladies. Those are high a
grade. He's just trying to make money.
And then time and time again, I would
date a sex worker over a regular girl.
Of course, hands down.
But why is your reasoning?
Because I feel like I have the right
frame of mind. I don't get jealous.
I wouldn't like bother. I think you would
actually come. You would be great. Yeah.
It'd be great for dating like a porn
girls dominate traits about him already.
Like what would he,
cause he doesn't want to because
some of the things he just said,
I think he would be like really?
He's the guy who wouldn't be bothered.
You know he'd be, he's
so, he wouldn't be weird.
Get Jealous and like even on a lower
level like a bartender or like a Hooters
waitress or something.
I would love to watch them work and like
pray on some dude and be like flirting
with him just to get their cash and then
we take their cash home and like smoke
weed and watch Netflix.
You
kind of a cook thing you like,
it's not a cook thing cause it's not
like I'm getting off on it but I can just
accept that that's rolls with it.
I can accept that that's the way they
make money and they can separate that from
them.
Loving me.
Josh is also low maintenance
and adaptable. Yes.
So like whatever the circumstances,
he's just going to go with it.
I'm like water baby.
I flow,
he flows.
But I imagine I would have like a sex
worker just because I imagine they've seen
it all. They've done been there, done
that. They're probably really sympathetic,
kind BYO. Oh, of course. I've been
through everything, you know? Yeah.
He would be a good match on that level.
And then every once in a
while he'd be like, you know,
why don't you eat my scrum?
And she'd be like, yeah, because she'd be,
and she'd be like, I'm the best of that.
And Blah, blah. Nothing phases.
I checked. No, no. True.
And into what your point is.
No one really gives a shit about the sex
workers and that's why these two dumb
dumbs got away with shit for
so long because it wasn't. Yes,
there's one of their dead
holes. Jesus. Yeah, no problem.
Strangled body. Yes. They found
this body, I forget which,
where that one was fun because they were
littering them throughout La County and
uh, they were found on the same days.
When did this happen? This is the 70s,
late seventies.
And it wasn't until they raped
and murdered two sex workers.
Oh. People started giving a
shit. People are like, Ooh.
And then they kind of connected
the dots from there. And was it a,
was the nostrils workers just like girls
they met at a bar kind of thing? Uh, no.
They were 12 year olds.
No.
What's the RFD line? Is that a bus
line? Do you know that? Oh, our TTD.
The rapid transit.
I wasn't sure if that's what that
meant or if it was like a short bus or
something. No. Okay. Our bus system and
then, I don't know what they call it now.
Rtd, but yes, they found them. Uh,
they got off of stop there last they were
seeing and then they were getting into
a car driven by one of these dudes and a,
that was the end of them.
That's when people started that
sniff and no kids though. Yes.
But to them it was almost the same thing.
These guys were the typical guys that
like once they're pimping business went
dry, they're like these fucking
whores. No one cares about them. Right.
I bet no one would care
if they went missing.
And then they started like laughing
about that and then they started cruising
around in their car posing as undercover
police officers. That's how they would,
oh my God. Yes, they
fake badges. Oh my God.
And then how did they get caught? They
got caught because they were just sloppy.
They were littering these bodies about
no one really connected the dots until
they murdered those two non sex workers.
And then they were kind of like, Whoa,
this is similar to this and this and this.
And then through their, one of their,
um, attempted victims. What
was this chick's name? Uh,
it was the daughter of an actor.
It's a,
her name is Catherine. Laura Baker.
It's Peter Laura's daughter. Oh my God.
So they attempted to kill her and they
abducted her and everything and they
aborted it because they found a picture
of her on her father's lap and they're
like, no shit. You're Peter
Lauren's daughter. I love
him. They let her go. Why?
They found a picture of
her on her father's lap,
like in her belongings and
Peter Lorre from from m is for
murder or whatever is great.
I love this guy because he played like
a killer or whatever. I'm also now,
now I'll have, you know, I
know this is a running theme.
I can cry to fellows had their
own ride or die and FTD RTD.
Yes. Really. Victoria Compton's
her name. There she is.
This woman was so in love with
Kenneth Biyanki. Oh my God.
That she,
once they were captured and
they were in jail and on trial,
she attempted to lure and uh,
kill a woman in a motel to
make it look like the hillside.
Stranglers were still on
the loose and we'll hack.
And Kenneth even gave her some
dude from jails Jizz to plant.
So it looked like a rate and she was
about to do all that. But she fucked up.
She fucked up. Yeah, she got caught. But
did she kill someone? No, she got like,
it wasn't a test. She fucked it
all up. Got got caught for it.
It was an attempt.
I tell you it's how you wouldn't do those
things that she attempted to strangle.
Yes. I never understand
what the, the attraction is.
Is it women who like that kind of
power that the serial killer has?
I don't know. Is it the the perception
of yeah, like strength and power.
Cause a lot of women like Charles Manson,
he had a wife before he died and he gets
celebrity celebrity, average Ramirez.
The Richard Mirrors, right? Yeah, the,
the night stalker. He had chicks into him.
Even like,
uh,
the dude who shot up Aurora movie theater
was like chicks were sending him nudes
and stuff.
Oh yeah.
Manson.
All the girls were in love with Charles
Manz even though he didn't technically
murder anybody. Right. Tom, you're
always bringing that point up to me.
He told people look younger, but they
followed his orders. Right, right, right.
I mean bad guy. Worst Guy, but
I dunno, it was worst guy. Um,
but yes, Victoria would, you
wouldn't do any of those things? No.
No, not for time. I throw his ass in
jail. She's still alive. By the way.
Do you think we could at least send her
a shirt and FTD? Our team. Oh my gosh.
She deserves that. If anyone
does, she's the real deal.
He says she's the Ogf tea RTD men.
I mean, who's ges? Would
you plant on a person?
If you are going to frame them for murder,
he was evil.
You'd have to extract the
ges to, Oh, how do you even
asking? Wow. What did they do to get it?
I know this guy,
he got some random dude in the prisons
jizz cheese money for it and I was like,
dude, got killed back. A smokes
all jerk off into this cup.
Really only probably had lord. I'm
with like, I just like to drink it.
Will you just leave it in a cup for
me? All right, put this in a body.
There's no way. He was like, what
I'm going to do is smuggle this.
Just have it planted on some.
Thinking about the logistics,
how do you smuggle ges out of a
prison? Oh, there's tons of ways.
What Josh,
what are you talking about?
The little smuggle all kinds
of knives and guns. Dope.
Is is liquid.
I mean you could smuggle that.
You could just like smuggle it
in your mouth. I'll and France.
Nobody
get a Dixie Cup or something and he's
little ball it out. All right guys.
Okie doke. There's tons of ways. Okay,
well, interesting. Well thank you.
What a ray of sunshine you've been.
There's a Jesus.
Now there's one more
gentleman is my favorite.
I hate the segment right now.
Let me get back to filthy porn.
I'm so terrified right now.
Bullies terrifies. Scary.
This is not Christina crime.
That last one was pretty. That
was pretty bad. I'm so scared.
This guy is now.
I mean,
I don't even know if I want to
tell you about this guy anymore.
Sounds like it's going to be bad.
This Guy Albert fish is his name. Oh,
look at that guy.
You think he could make some great youtube
videos if he had it back in the day,
right? He's just sweet. Imagine that guy
asking you to come over and Piss on him.
Okay.
Sky Empty in there. Oh, you don't
have to. No fucking idea. He's full,
but not with a soul. No,
she looks like a refugee.
This gentlemen is a child rapist
and accountable. I can't hear
this shit. I'm a mother of two,
you know that I can't even
walk. What's that? That, what is
that? This guy has a fucked up life. Okay.
He was born into a terrible home.
His mother was an alcoholic,
a prostitute,
and she sent him away to an orphanage
where he was beat by nuns and shit cause
it's like the 18 hundreds.
And he started to enjoy the
beatings a little bit too much.
So as he grew up,
this guy even got married,
had kids at six fucking kids and it's uh,
noted that he did never was known
to attack or abuses on children,
but he would have them and their friends
slap his ass with that little guy right
there with nails coming
through it. Yes. Okay.
And that is not even the expense,
like mild for this cool dude
and this far as what he likes.
This is kids to do that. Yes.
Hey Son. Yeah. Yeah. Hey,
why don't you get your friend bill to
come over and slap dad's ass with the
fucking with nail nail
pat. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hold this guy also
enjoyed a little activity.
Now I don't know if you've seen Tom
doing this or caught him doing it.
It's would be a red flag. But
go ahead. This guy liked to uh,
put rose stems up his urethra.
Yes.
I've seen them posing a mirror with it,
with those in there.
This guy, this guy right
here is a pioneer by the way.
He's like a g o d in the body
modification community can be clearly.
Yeah,
he has,
like I have noted there are five aspects
of body modification people do for like
enjoyment today that this guy was all
about like a play piercing. For instance.
Uh, this guy, you stick inserts,
sewing needles under his fingernails
as a game and he has to do with
not only that, when he
was a debt, when he died,
they found 29 sewing needles in his
pelvis that he would insert through.
I'll, let's see if I get this word right.
The perineal. Do you know where that is?
Yeah, yeah, exactly. It's your tank. He'd,
he would stay those on them up in there.
And there is a, I don't know if I included
that picture. That's a crime scene.
I might've,
I did.
I can't believe I forgot to include the
picture of the x ray of his pelvis with
all those needles in it.
Now what is this letter here?
Is this audio someone read that's an audio
drama to [inaudible] of a letter that
he wrote. This is how he got caught.
Because eventually, like all of them,
they get sloppy. Yep. But this,
that's the time, by the way,
the time to get away with things late
18 hundreds early 1,980 course. Oh,
before forensic. Yeah. DNA. And so
Albert's like toward the end of his life,
right?
He has been doing all this shit.
He's into all this like a
torture and everything like that.
He loves all that crap.
What he decides now he reads an ad in a
paper where an 18 year old gentlemen is
talking about, he's like hardy stock
looking for citizenship. You know,
this is like the 18 hundreds classified.
This guy's looking for work.
So Albert answers the ad just to go check,
Holla at your boy thinking like,
I'm going to eat this fucking guy. Yeah.
Uh, because he loves eating human beings.
And so he shows up there and
he meets the Guy Thinking,
I'm going to murder this guy. But then
he meets his little sister and is like,
nope, I'm eating hurt. Oh Geez.
So then he like tells him like,
I'll come back and let
you know about the job.
I'll be back here in a little
bit and we'll talk about it.
So he comes back and he goes, you know
what? It's my nieces birthday. Okay.
You mind if I take grace to the
party? And they're like, yeah,
go ahead. Creepy old man. What?
And they let him do that and
they never saw her again.
And then years later after, you
know, she's been missing. I mean,
they assume she's dead probably, you know,
but they don't know have any answers.
He sends them this anonymous letter,
uh,
which I gave you a dramatic reading of it.
I really don't want to hear this jar.
My dear.
Mrs Bud on June 3rd,
1928 I called on you at four oh six
West 15th Street and brought to you pot,
cheese and strawberries.
We had lunch.
Grace sat on my lap and kissed me,
right.
Oh No, thank you. Taking her
to a party, you said yes,
she can go to
an named Dee home in Westchester. I had
already picked out when we got there.
I told her to remain outside.
She picked wild flowers.
I went upstairs and stripped all my
clothes off. I knew if I did not,
I would get our blood on them.
Oh no thank you. Push. No, no, no more.
Can't. I can't. I can't.
Went to the window and called her and I
hid in the closet until she was in the
room.
When she saw me all naked,
she began to cry and
tried to run downstairs.
I grabbed her and she said
she would tell her Mama,
there's a twist.
I stripped her naked.
How she did kick by 10 scratch.
I choked her to death and Carter into
small pieces so I could take the meat to
my rooms,
cook and eat it.
How sweet and tender her little
ass was roasted in the oven.
It took me nine days to eat her in time.
Shit.
But
no,
I did not fuck her though.
I could have if I wished
she died a virgin.
Well that is the nice solace at the
end, Huh? Right side to all that.
Cause you not fucking bring
kid things over. Come on man.
I can't hear this stuff. Albert
fish though. Kind of a pioneer.
He was eating ass before.
It was cool. Okay.
Right.
Find a real,
you find a real savage out there.
You've got to get her to Albert Fish,
ladies and gentlemen,
Josh.
Oh my God,
I'm starving.
Thanks for having me having
me. Yeah, thanks. Bye. Bye. Now
can we stick to porn on the website?
You know the next dark web thing?
You've got to top this, right? Ah,
fuck. He's going to get hard though.
You can do it Josh, anywhere.
Anybody can see you coming up.
I'm going to be at a helium
in Buffalo, New York, uh,
for New Year's Eve with rich
Voss. That's right. Hell yeah.
And then I'm going to be in San Francisco
with you the week after that. Sonic.
January 4th and fifth. That's
right. All right. Thanks Josh.
No problem. Terrible. All right.
So we just wrapped up the, um, one of the
most deprived and depressing segments,
everyone of this show.
And uh,
we want to keep that energy rolling.
So we brought in one of the most deprived
human beings we could ever think of it
to have on here. I will say this,
man, I'm not always an early adapter.
I feel like I was an early adapter early
fan of Kyle done against Instagram page,
the funniest Instagram page.
I think you might've been the very first.
It was the first person that like
posted something of mine that,
that blew it up. Well, and did you
send Joe Rogan stuff? Oh, so yeah,
you started my whole,
uh,
Instagram year and Tom Talks about your
Instagram feed to me and got me on it.
Did you, were you annoyed
or where you were like, oh,
this is great Instagram fan.
So when I saw your shit I was like,
this is great.
Here's the thing too is like the,
I I've talked about this many
times on the show that um,
throughout my life,
nothing makes me laugh harder still
than getting a reaction of disgust or
contempt for my mother on something.
Like it's still the thing,
it's like it's in the DNA where
it reminds me of like, you know,
burping at the table and being
like chastised for doing that.
And it would make me laugh.
And that video that you do
where you do the chicken,
but one where I was like,
is this real?
And like did you really first
one was real surprise her.
Sometimes she, but she'll know
I'm doing something man. The,
the fact that the shit out of
her. Right. I remember this one.
So this bit was like he's doing a
character, you're doing a with Craig or,
and, and you're going like, hey mom.
And she was like, what? I guess what,
what chicken button? And
she's like, all right.
And then like she's on the
phone, mom. Guess what man?
And she's like,
she's doing that thing like I'm on.
And You keep like,
cause it feels like you know a kid
basically like I know what you're talking.
She's like, Oh for crying
what? Chicken Butt?
And then it just keeps
building until you do it.
She was in the bathroom and then like
in the middle of the night she's like,
oh it's fluorescent. Had those two
are set up. But that was perfect.
Nailed it. Yeah, she's good. She
nailed it. She gets nervous and uh, uh,
self doubt,
which I recognized that was you
fooled me cause I was like Holy Shit.
She's, it's four in the morning and
she's like, oh chicken by. Yeah.
So that was like its own lane
of a type of video style.
But then I think what's really blown
up is like your face swap character.
Um, cause you have, you
know, like you do Trump ones,
the Jenners the Kardashians. Yeah. Baby.
Yeah. They, uh,
I first started just doing straight up
and then I was trying to figure out how
to get them to talk to each other cause
it's people who have done it where they
just cut back and forth.
So I thought about the facetiming
so can all see them at once,
which works for the town.
When you do that family,
you're so good at the I put
a new one up today. Yeah.
This shit makes me why you left
your house burned down
for a minute there.
I thought I was going to suffer
the shame. Famous my nuts. Shack.
You get all your,
the first thing I did when I saw the
flames just grabbed my crotch and my
Alexander McQueen stiletto pumps.
Yeah.
Then I ran back to get my Louis
Vuitton alligator duffle bag show.
Beautiful.
Like demands attention shy 17
Jimmy Choo and my dog checkers.
But there was only enough time to
save tool. Those things girls. Oh,
I think Sophie's choice. What's
that? What did you choose?
Oh, checkers is fucking dad. Yeah.
I had at least she's got my old
balls and stick to play with up us.
Oh Man. Oh my God. You do that? Vacant
Kardashians think so, man. Oh yeah.
Just put one up. Oh, this job one
sounds great. Yeah. CAITLIN's,
wow. I love when people jump in. I like
when stormy jumps in on somebody's. Yeah.
Really funny.
Yeah.
Caitlin jumps in on now and they're
going to their magic and hit him from the
lady I love about stormy two.
Stormy's character is basically
an invention in a way.
Like it's not really that storming body.
Yeah.
I don't know how she talks about
it's perfect. You're like, oh yeah,
that's the perfect character. If they
want you to imagine. Yeah. He's like, Oh,
I'm not going to swallow. You can knock
anyone fucking your whole cog. Gotcha.
Halfway down. Can we watch
this one? Yeah. Let's watch it.
This is the, this is a, what do you
call it? Hot off the press premiere.
Okay. And we got who we got here.
Let's Dr Phil and Bill Maher. Bill,
what the Fuck Your Bill Maher impression
you always knew you could do bill. Uh,
I've done it for a few years.
Yeah. Do you remember doing him?
Like did you used to watch, you
know, whatever his show was?
Yeah and I yeah I was auditioning for
like mad TV or something and sort of try
to get it done and someone told me
once about like people who nail it,
I've always like, you know, oh my God,
I just got a flashback to
auditioning for mad TV. Yeah, me too.
I did a couple of times I feel,
I feel the chill cause like I remember
that I was doing something that was
working like yeah, joke wise. And then
she goes like, do you do any impressions?
And I go like, Nah. And she goes,
and I remember her specifically going
tried Jack Black and I was like,
no. Okay. And I was like,
I'm Jack Black. Hi, I'm Jay.
I was like, Hey, what's up?
Like just imagine something just spiraling
out of control. And she was like, yeah,
now that didn't really
work. I'm like, yeah,
I didn't come in here saying I do a
Jack Black impression and your left,
you left her with that impression.
And then she was just like, yeah,
that wasn't really a, yeah, yeah. Spot on.
Impression, the Jack Black and I was like,
I know a random person.
To me it has to be hard about those mad
TV auditions back in the day is that
everyone was probably doing the same
fucking impressions is it was the same.
He was like Brittany Spears for walking.
Yeah.
You really have to blow people away
with something original like that.
It's so hard. I went in, I auditioned for,
sorry live and you know they fly out to
New York and everything and while ago.
Yeah, 2010 okay. And I,
I like had evidence would be the
most nerve wracking thing. Right?
I was out of my mind because like
you're in a hotel room for two days by
yourself running.
I just ran it over and over and I was
like minutes and then I get there and I
just was not in a place where I could
perform. I was just so nervous. Seriously.
Yeah. And I was like please
not first. And they were like,
first up is Kyle done again? God.
And then they are miking man,
I could tell I was,
I didn't have my a fist.
They can't get to your
facilities when you're nervous,
when you're really nervous.
You couldn't even see the guy counting
me in was this the camera and goes,
I'll count you in three, two,
one you'll write in your stuff.
It was really intense. Three
to one. So I go out there,
I'm really hanging onto this and I
walk out there and like Lorne Michaels,
everyone's on a table over here to
the left. And I just walked down.
I kind of stood there like
waiting and nothing was happening.
And then Lauren goes, hello, like hello?
Like say hi to us. I was like, oh hi, hi.
Sorry. And I just kept staring,
waiting for that, count it.
And the guy told me it was coming, it
wasn't coming. And then Lauren goes,
are you okay? Which is like the
auditions now over the not started.
So then I started to explain that, well
that guy and that guy goes three, two,
you didn't wanna get in trouble. And I
couldn't, like I was trying to do, build,
the voices weren't coming out of my mouth.
I was just too nervous.
I'm scared. But they, in
their defense, they have to,
you gotta be able to perform live and
yeah, it should be a nerve wracking,
a addition, whole law. He's nice.
And that's a nice thing to
encourage young. The uh,
I was talking to one of the Africa,
one of the big comedy casting directors
here in town and I just for something
with her and I was like, you
know, every time you're the best,
like she's always super sweet. Um, makes,
makes the situation, Juliet,
Juliet might be great.
It makes you feel really engaged and you
know what I mean? Like if she goes like,
do you have any questions? If you're like,
I dunno. Do you have anything to add to?
Yeah, we, the thing is I
think they're really looking
for it to be read like this.
You're like, I've had, I have, uh,
I was still used to her a few times.
She cast me in something and then I went
to another one where I asked the same
way where I was like, uh,
is there anything that you
want to tell me about it?
And she's like, that's for you to decide.
Oh, I was like, oh, so the answer is no.
You're going to have anything to share.
Like you just,
you don't have to be a dick about
it. Like, yeah, there's like a,
I stopped going to auditions.
I don't know why I have an agent.
I write the checks and
I go, wow, what's this?
You got me zero things.
Yeah. In like a decade. No,
auditions even. I went on an
audition a year and a half ago.
That's the last audition. Yeah, I got it.
And then never got another audition for
you now I may got it. I should leave.
That was just one of those
things where it's on your to
do list. Oh yeah, yeah. No,
I usually leave today. Yeah, send the
email on the way out. Okay, cool. I mean,
seriously. Yeah, but then he
gives you, you know, you go, well,
what if something comes up? But
no, but you get another agent
though. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No,
you're, you're not wrong. Yeah. Yeah.
Um, all right, so we got Dr Phil,
we got Bill Maher and we have,
that's what I can do. I can be alone,
not auditioning. You just make something.
It's hilarious. Right? That's
the thing is that you found this,
I'm always so amazed at people that
take what's given to them in technology.
Like what you've done with face
swapping and then how are you,
I don't know what you're using to even,
I can't give away my seat.
Oh, how do I build it? Yeah.
I'll just do the one who talks the most
first and I'll, I'll make like a script.
So when I'm talking I'll
be talking in my mouth.
So at times out when I have to do
the other ones, I'll say their lines.
I love this DIY entertainment
purposes just for silly, but people,
this is what comedians are so great at it.
It's like he's taking what's available.
We've taken what's available
to you in this time and space,
the technology and then making it work
for what you do and making it work in
your favor. Like it's, I just think it's
so great. I have a lot of free time.
Such a great era we live in.
Yeah,
it is cool how open it is and the things
that are going to be coming or going to
be surprising. I'm not sure what
to make it. If you want to make it,
you're fucking making this show is fucking
Megan. Just make it all right here.
Here's the latest and greatest,
the newest version,
a from Kyle done against Instagram page.
It's at Kyle Dunnigan one.
Here we go.
Okay guys. I got someone to fill out
a person for the golf game tomorrow,
but it's a girl. Okay. Oh good.
Is she a hot piece of ass clothes?
She's older and use to have a penis.
Oh,
not Caitlyn again,
if she hits from the ladies tees this time
I'm not fucking playing. Okay. No, no,
we, I looked great meds. Chased this
time now big. Get her on the horn. Oh,
Haribo eyes. I'm going to wear my
Vera Wang Miniskirt tomorrow. Yap.
Or as I like to call it,
my Vira no ag Gabay man.
Caitlin, we respect you as a woman.
So we want to be delicate here.
You're going from the men's
tees. You've got dude DNA. Sorry.
Watch your mouth. Ash. How well you were
the number one male athlete in the world.
You're not starting 40 fucking
yards ahead of us. Okay.
Why are you pushing his
head from the ladies tees?
And I'll hit from the pros and still kick
your panty. Asher's we, I don't know.
Is it weird that just gave me a boner
doctor Phil. Oh Great. I love it.
It's so fucking funny, man.
Thank you. Will you, uh,
you started my uh,
uh,
W I don't wanna call explosion cause
people have a lot more followers.
But you got over 400,000,
I think I had 19,000 when you've
posted a no, I have like 407.
So that's was wild. Then you
start posting seven. My Shit.
Do you feel like I owe you? Yeah, of
course. Of course. Yeah, absolutely.
Especially like after what
you put me through and, um,
where are we did odd
together and you made me
go in your dressing room and like,
why should you do all this stuff?
That was a bad time. That's lifetime.
That's what you owe me for. Um,
I'll tell you later off my, I don't want
to get her showing up for a lady's ears.
Um,
but the bill Maher one is just,
I don't think sometimes there's
public figures who you realize, oh,
I've never heard an impression of
that person. And then when you do it,
that's the one that's, that's what,
what stands out about Bill Maher?
I don't think I've ever heard
someone do an impression.
And when you do the impression I have
to double check. It's not him talking.
You paypal, I went on a
trip with him. You did.
This is so random, but like
military, well I was going,
I was going to Hawaii
with my girlfriend and uh,
she missed a plane and it broad,
so she a bitch. It was Sarah
Silverman. You Fendler God,
Bill Marras good friends with her and he's
like, just come on our plane. You know,
he had his own private jet so he went on
there and it clearly like he was bummed
I was a tag along. Ah,
Timmy. He was anyway. Yeah,
he really was.
He made no effort to make
me feel at all comfortable.
But look, by the way, Ron, huge shocker.
I mean bill seems like the kind of guy
that would go out of his way to make
everybody feel comfortable. He had never
heard a story where it was like, oh,
and then build it this.
I did a standup show with him ages ago,
over a decade ago,
and I was on the same lineup as him and
he kept asking me to bring him drinks
and I was like, I'm a comic. And
I did tell him like two times.
I'm not a waitress here, bro.
Like I can't even remember.
It was so long ago was
it was at a restaurant.
We don't want all fair and
bringing me a drink. Yeah. Yeah.
How would you say you bring me a drink?
Sweethearts.
Sweeter.
I was in a,
he was in a dressing room
and at the Pasadena Club was
ice house and it's packed
and there's nowhere to let go hang like
all the comedians have to be and he
kicked everyone out of the dressing
room or I'll just stand there like he,
he did, we're not, we weren't allowed
her own in the green room. You know,
it's weird. We're all standing in the
hallway because bill needs the green room.
Bill needs his space
so it needs a space to read over what
the riders told him to say tonight. Okay,
fine. Yeah. Um, you know,
it's always amazing to me when people
are like that because it's so much easier
just to be nice to people. But then
you learn their store and you'll, oh,
they make sense.
I get that.
I didn't learn too much about someone
because you always end up liking them,
you know, you go, oh, that's why
they're like that. Why is he like that?
It's probably a combination of stuff maybe
ignored by girls and he's younger and
maybe a,
I don't know.
His Dad did something and we saw being
tough is a way of getting respect.
Sure.
He looks at people who are nice as weak.
That's what Trump is like a little bit,
but that's big in my culture
and Hungarian stuff. Yeah.
If you're like,
Americans are like donkeys to them.
Kind of like my step mom.
Like if we go to a restaurant
and the waiter will be
super nice, like, Hey folks,
how you doing? It was met with
contempt. You calling goes folks,
we got to fight and like it's seen
as total weakness. Yeah. Interesting.
Yeah. Well that Rooskie culture
too. You know the, you know the,
if you see the like Putin a photo ops,
it's always oh yeah. Oh yeah. Because
they think were goofballs. If we go like,
yeah, smile, joy. Oh yeah.
Like what are you a fucking
clown? Yeah. Like soft smiling.
Why are you smiling? So say, yeah.
Who's that? That's cultural. Yeah.
These are always not smiling photos.
Yeah. It started like, oh, right.
Like if you look at early photography,
I guess they just stand there for so long.
That's why. Yeah, that's true.
But it's every photo like early
twenties thirties everyone's like,
yeah. And that's, that's the
lovely photo of the person.
Just a marriage, like my grandparents
marriage photo. They're just like,
it looks like on a terrible time.
Yeah.
Yeah. So if I, I try because I want to
look cool. You know how some people,
comedians can take pictures with fans
and they keep a straight face and they
look really interesting.
Like it's like they're making a choice.
I look so unfriendly when I don't smile.
You always look on friendly. Really? Well,
you didn't want to, oh, it's the worst.
Like I just looked so depressed and like,
what does he look?
Let me see. Well, it's very slight,
really. It feels very like
eastern blocky and shitty.
Some people have got formed around
a frowny, oh, I don't have a frowny,
but you carry, you look like
you care to be look cool and no,
that's the thing is I want to look cool.
Yeah.
And then every time someone wants
to take a photograph with me,
I'm so amazed that anybody wants to, yeah.
But I'm like, I'm like, oh, yeah, sure.
Okay. Yeah, no, I got to
do it like I'm too excited.
[inaudible] song on too long mirror,
like ready to go. I want to
be good looking and I was
still hanging on to that.
I didn't,
I've maybe peaked at a six and I'll try.
It's just getting uglier every day today.
Jane. Yeah. Yeah. We look in the mirror.
I think I'm tired. Yeah. And then
I go, no, you're dying. Yeah,
you are. Yeah, totally. Yeah. You know
what's nice is that we have some like,
so that we're able to do things like this,
we have some help,
like a nanny at the house.
Yeah.
And a lot of times she'll tell me
how tired I look. Yeah. And um,
it's something that's new that like
sometimes it was a thought of mine where I
look in the mirror and you think they
look tired, but then you're like,
don't beat yourself up. And then
I'll see her and she's like, dumb.
You look very tired today. And I'm like,
I feel okay. Yeah. I'm glad I look tired.
And is it, you're always, you always
look like that? Yeah, I did notice.
I think I was looking like that.
No one was telling me that,
but now I get to hear it all the time.
That's true. It's nice. I want to Ne,
I want like a night nanny just for me.
Like when you're typing or the couch,
you gotta get to bed and Floss,
pick you up.
They floss your teeth and lay it
out or your bum. That'd be awesome.
How do your bum,
yes.
Maybe we could start this other thing
about like falling apart as we age is that
because I,
I was really even really fat at 1718 you
realize that a lot of your friends that
weren't, they get fat as they get in
their forties and then you're like, oh,
you look bad now you got fat. But because
I was fat then. Oh, that's cool. I'm like,
I either look better than I did or
I maintained. Oh, that's nice. Yeah.
It was a silver lining for us.
So if you're like young and fat,
you have that to look forward to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Sorry,
I forgot what I was going to fucking, God
damn it. I bet it was going to be good.
Here's the thing,
as long as you can stay skinny as you age,
I feel like that's the key.
You don't want to be fat and old.
If you can maintain your weight.
Does it give away the,
for me from my body,
I have an unusual body
but I can very thin,
but my gut will just come
straight out like a pregnant man.
You ever thought about just like skipping
food altogether? Yeah, there's a family.
They just eat off the universe and light
and you see that article last week,
it's gotta be a lie.
But they have kids and they say they just
like stare at the sun and you take the
universe of energy and they
don't eat food. They're called.
There's also a group of
people called breadth Ariens
where they breathe in. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Hey, that's
pretty cool. I do that too.
Are you a food guy though? I mean, is that
your indulgence? No, I, I love food. But,
uh, I mean they had a lot of chocolate
too much, but, uh, but now I'm not a fool.
I, yeah. I'm like, Nah,
I have tiny bones in guy,
but like my BMI,
BMI is bad. Like my, my
hips are really smart bike,
which goes from like hip, stomach
ratios. Good. Yeah. I'm an illusion.
There's something very, uh, lives, a
lot of weird things about my body. Like,
don't look right now, but
like, I hurt my neck one time.
This is actually a weird story,
but I was having a dream.
I was twisting off the top
to a giant coke bottle,
can like a seven foot thing
and I'm twisting it and I
woke up in agonizing pain
with my hands wrapped around my head.
Yeah.
Twisted my own head.
So then I know that sounds
almost unbelievable. Yeah.
And never happened again.
Just one time weird thing. And
you're like, ah, my fucking neck.
I woke up just staring
at the ceiling and pain.
Aren't those dreams the most
unbelievable. When you, when you are,
it's so vivid and you get
up and you're like, oh,
and you realize you're not there. Yeah.
Yeah. I feel like I want those more.
I don't have it then. They're
good. They're good. Yeah.
You know what I used to do
when I had head gear as a kid,
I would rip off the head gear in my
slack. Throw it across the world. Yeah,
you too. Yeah. Yeah. And I wake up
in the morning, I'm like, oh my God,
I am not wearing my head gear.
And it was like in the closet.
I'd thrown it across to hop out.
And the kit your cheek, did your,
did your head turning thing actually
resulted in neck injury? Yeah,
I had a neck brace on my Instagram. That
picture you can see a neck brace. Yeah.
And I had
it on for almost a year, but the
reason I could have had it on the last,
what I realized is I,
the muscles go around the injury and they
like tighten around it. And I didn't,
I didn't, uh, I kept tweaking
it, thinking it was still hurt,
but it was to the muscles that
needed to be stretched out.
But I went to the doctor,
I've got an extra eye and the doctor was
looking at my extra way for a while and
uh, then he calls it another
dogs. Hey John, come in
here. Cause another doctrine,
another staring at Max. Right. You don't
want your doctor to look at your ex.
Right. Like he's never seen. So I was
like, what am I dying? Like what's up?
And he goes, you have the neck
of a seven foot man. Why? Yeah,
lot. That's what they
told me. And that was,
that had anything to do with the injury
or there now? Oh, just in general? Yeah.
Like your neck. Like uh, let me see that.
Oh yeah. I know. I don't
think it was seven feet,
but I think it looks like a graceful
neck. It's very regal. But my,
I'm five nine so I have the
legs of a 12 year old girls.
It's crazy that you did that to yourself
and your sleep because don't they say
you can't actually physically like punch
yourself or harm yourself because the
body won't, your brain won't allow,
but I guess when you're, yeah, you can,
you can do it too. And if you're asleep
you could do some bad things, I'm sure.
Cause you're, you don't have that
awareness. Oh my God, that's terrifying.
I feel like I've grown out of,
I was always like doing like
things were like a dream.
I had some treme issues, not sleep
walking, but like moving around.
A lot of really active sleeper
just kind of went away.
That's good. Yeah. But uh, yeah,
I grew up in a, I'm just gonna
start talking about myself. So, uh,
my name's Kyle and Kyle.
What's your middle name?
Anthony. Oh, it's good to eat.
Galliano um,
I didn't mean to hijack this show.
We're talking to do it. No, we want to
know more about you. I was just like,
thinking about myself and started talking
about something we love your commeddia.
Um, yeah. What do you
want to know about me?
Give you a question and only child,
no.
Last baby of how many?
Three total. Three total.
Yeah.
And those two older brother cop.
And a hardest job by the way.
Not hardest may have,
but I mean he just goes, you go where
people are being assholes all day long,
all day. It's called racist
stuff. He just tested,
keep taking it and you go on with the
turn on the TV and the TV kind of tells
you you're a racist cop.
He said to take it to take everything.
Is He east coast guy? Good guy though.
Yeah. Good guy. There's some good cops.
I mean cops do.
There's,
you know what happens is we highlight
the bad cops cause there's bad people in
there. Their stories. Yeah. Well yeah.
So you know the stories about the bad
ones are so bad that that becomes kind of
the narrative for cats. But there's
obviously good cops. The cops,
especially the older I get
and I'm kids and stuff,
mortgaged property and a lot
of them come over, come over.
They got a lot of pressure
on them and it's just a bear.
You have to have a really strong sense
of yourself and patients because even you
go back to the precinct,
everyone's kind of being an asshole
because they're bringing in, they're like,
we're done ride alongs.
Yeah.
I've done a few in different cities and
it's always an entertaining and learning
experience. I've done it in North
Carolina. I went out with a cop,
I went out with a black cop. We wanted
to go different experiences, you know.
Then I went out in Tacoma with a cop.
We,
you studying it for a role or are
you doing this the first time I,
I knew the guy from another job I had to
because he worked part time at cops can
have sometimes multiple jobs.
Yeah. Which is kind of wild.
At one time was a fan of this show and
one time it was for a research thing for
a role and that,
but that was here in Hollywood.
And what I found was that most in
all three different areas, the um,
the cops dealt the most with just
mental illness all the time. Yeah. Yeah.
Just all day. I was like, how much
of your like day is mental illness?
And they're like,
like 85% of these people were either
drunk drugs or mental illnesses and then
like they're like fucked up
things like the drop off.
So somebody who's just mentally ill
at a hospital and then they're like,
he's like,
I'll pick them up tomorrow somewhere else.
I'm dropping off at a different
hospital. Oh Wow. And that, that's there.
You see the Ron Coleman documentary on
Netflix, the Ron Coleman. Ronnie Coleman.
The bodybuilder? No. And Mr,
I've heard from multiple people.
Unbelievable.
He had a fulltime cop.
He's a cop fulltime and mystery
at the same time. Which no,
he was a cop as he was Mister Olympia.
No one has ever had a full time job and
been Mr Lindhout move and be like with
that.
You know what I mean?
Like how did he run after somebody
with that just giant such a monster?
Well now he's supposed to be in a
wheelchair. The doctors are like,
you should be in a wheelchair. His back
is so screwed up, but he's so strong.
He's like willing himself around on these
like crutches and he still gets up at
4:30 AM every morning and goes to the gym.
The doctors are like,
don't do that. Go. And he just
keeps going. It's pretty impressive.
I'm like trying to be wild
and a lot like that guy.
So you have this pig brother
and then your other sibling,
she is a, uh, pig mum.
She is, yeah. She said,
mom, mom, she picked mom, but
she's not a cop. Oh, thank God.
Just too two kids.
I always wonder because
like you have this quirky,
it's a very defined sense of humor.
Right.
And then it's the kind of thing where
to me, like the way I would phrase it,
all these things are subjective and
the way, but I would still check,
I would describe it like,
people who I think are funny
would find you funny. They,
you know what I mean? And
are your siblings, are they
like, he's fucking weird?
Or do they,
it was,
I felt very alone and like what I thought
was funny when I was younger. Yeah.
My brother's cool. And, uh, he,
he makes suggestions are always about
like farting or something. Sure.
So we like him already. Yeah. He's
cool. Yeah. But your big sister,
my big sister does not understand me.
We love her. We love each other. Right.
I mean I always, I was an
odd child too, you know,
they didn't test for things back then,
but I would apply a kite for hours and
just pee my pants and just keep flying.
I was that kind of kid focused and
once you were on something, yeah,
I would get hyper. I think it's a burger
types. Your videos. It's my videos.
Your videos are hyper focused. You'd
get distracted for hours. Yeah.
I didn't make that just to
show people kind of do that.
And I think it's uh, I don't
know. It hurts me in some ways.
Like I leave my car door
or open the other day,
just I'll just leave my car running.
Stuff like that happens.
If I'm thinking about something else,
it's dangerous.
I probably shouldn't have
a kid talking about before.
It's dangerous. That's
interesting. Are Our boys,
like Ellis has kinda hyperfocused where
he can do an activity from the time he
was, I don't know, 15 months old,
like he'll just play with water in
the sink for literally the first time.
It was two and a half hours
and I just let him, yeah.
What about on the love cycle?
Are you a Tinder?
The love I just got on some
apps. It's going terribly.
Yeah. But you just started,
oh,
Don,
will you please tell us what kind of
picture are you leading with and what type
of bio are you putting up there?
It's very important.
I don't have that many pictures of myself.
You putting up a good big picture of,
yeah, I'm the first profile pic. I guess
they'll click a nine, nine and a half.
Okay. Oh Wow. Um,
second one's probably a
little less than that then.
They're not great picks. I didn't
think a lot about it, but they're fine.
I look fine. But you're not
doing jokey pictures go? No,
just like straight up whatever.
But I had a breakup, uh,
in early September and it was,
we were long distance
for a couple of years.
Then she moved in and five days
later we broke up. Why, you know,
how it is to move an entire person's
life into your, wait a minute.
How long were you together?
Long Distance. Like two years.
And we're talking like another coast?
No, Las Vegas. Okay. That's not too far.
And I thought there was a,
there was a little bit of jealousy and
going through my things breaking into my
emails stuff. Which is not
accepted after you moved in? No,
this is before I justified like,
oh,
once she moves in because everything
else was great. She'll see, I don't know,
do anything and she'll like,
um, not be jealous or something.
But when she moved in I realized,
Oh this is just how it's going to always
be if my whole life maybe worse and
five days later,
yeah,
this was five days later and it hit me
at Starbucks and Whitney Cummings walked
in in that moment oddly
that sees you like that.
Actually, she has a picture of me
with like my hands and my head,
but she gave me good advice.
Should go back to the house,
break up and then leave.
Don't get to negotiation is good advice
because I went back as a really bad,
but I was like, you know, you stay
here and you know I'm going to go. And,
but then she didn't leave.
Like I was homeless for like nine hours.
She didn't leave the house. She didn't
leave. And then she texted me, okay,
I'm gone. You can cut back. I go back,
it's dark now. Lights are off. Cars gone.
She's not gone. She's in
the house hiding in my, no,
no. You know, like a
murderer. What sounds good.
John Molina is like a murderer.
You chair.
Um, so I, yeah,
I went in my house and my dog came up
to me who I talked to like an insane
person and I was, this just came out
of me. I go tough night to my dog,
which she must've heard
here. Oh God. Yeah.
And I turned the corner.
It's like a hey,
but wait a week.
So she's a nightmare.
And then tough night to my dog and
then I turned the corner. I was like,
oh look, I made a, another um,
feminine sound and then she kinda got
up and got our stuff and didn't like,
she tried to like join it a
whole hog for a little bit.
Like how did you initially
realize that someone's,
that you feel the energy or you hurt?
Oh,
I will turn the corner and
I was terrified. You saw
her? Yes. And you're like,
fuck yeah. I was like, Huh? Like that. Did
you go, like you said you were gone? No,
cause she immediately started
like trying to pull me down.
They just hold may kind of stuff. I
wanted to maybe have, you see Kay,
maybe makeup,
but I think top night and he made
her feel like not that attractive.
So she left. But anyway,
since went on bumble,
went on hinge and a, I've
had, I try to smash dog,
but why don't you get on Tinder? I, I'm
actually want a relationship. Really?
Yeah. I mean I'm all forced mansion. Maybe
I should say that. That's cool. Yeah.
I like just banging. Yeah, Bro. Why don't
you do a, why don't you do a bang to get,
cause you got to get the relationship
out of your system. Get a fresh bang,
then go into looking for the relief.
You know what I mean? Bang. Bang.
My way to love. Well, I'm saying
just get a bang out of the way. Yeah.
You got to bus the first
post relationship. You got
to clean those pipes out.
Yeah. You got to meet some Tinder
chicks. You know Tinder chicks are cool.
I have come all over my face, so just go
on Tinder. Yeah. All right. Sounds way.
Cray cray though. Yeah, she was.
I'm what's up with your picker as a
Patti Stanger but she was great in every
other aspect of stalking and
that kind of being, yeah,
by allying. Sure. Just two bars.
He's hiding in the home as that.
That was it.
Everything else funny that
you should taste the regs.
I mean she can do the sunny side up
going through. You're going, man,
I ask you this because I want an a day
and I think this is inappropriate with
this girl. Oh boy. I inappropriate
like bad at this stuff.
So I try to be a good guy and like
I plan the date and I do this thing.
So you know you're here. You're
supposed to do, that's enough.
Let's see what it says.
Yo Joe Mother fucker. Yo.
It's kind of inappropriate isn't
it? Yeah. I thought it was just me.
So I plan this data at a paint and
sip, you know, that is paint and
drink wine.
That's kind of a cute idea.
That correct the date one date two.
Okay. And we have a little bit,
uh, okay. So I go, uh,
it's texts ends with like,
great, see you there. See you then. Great.
You know, and so the day of I write,
Hey, do you wanna meet there at
some, uh, six 45? And she writes, um,
are we still going? Yeah, that's a
weird answer. Like, why would we,
yeah, see. And I said, what do you mean?
And she did, I haven't heard from you.
So I assume we just weren't
having a read for how long,
exactly two days. We'd shored up
the day and the day of, I was like,
how about this time? That's it. Hmm. So
anyway, then this whole thing blew up. We,
we, uh, saw each other
again. Wait a minute. Yeah.
So the date was fine. Like what did you
end up going? Yeah. And it was okay.
It just was, that was a weird thing. She
was just being really insecure. I, yeah,
I think no filter.
And she felt insulted that I,
that you didn't call or the day before
all saying there's rules and I did so
many things right.
I think I planned the thing,
I bought that there's like a
hundred bucks. I mean I'm a okay.
You gotta check in though.
You got to confirm the date.
24 hours. I would confirm,
but it was confirmed it two days prior,
but then the day before be like, Hey,
are we still good? Was the
day or maybe the day of, okay,
are we still good for tonight? Cause
that's what he did. He come up. Oh.
And then she, yeah, I kind of,
I might, sorry, I misunderstood.
So I think you're getting two
days before he's like, hey,
we'll meet up on a couple of days. That's
fine. And then the day of, he's like,
we're still good. Normally
that's where the inbounds, yeah,
I fought mixed suddenly there's
like months ago and by, yeah,
that's silly.
So we had as followup day.
Is this an interesting story because
you guys can just cut this out.
I don't know. No, no, no, no. Um,
all right. So then we had this, uh,
this is, this is my first foray
into dating. I love it after this.
This is what happens. So, um,
yeah, I'm getting too distracted to crazy
girls. I could tell you right now. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Your pickers
fucked up. Yeah. Well, this is the
only person that I've matched with,
so it's really bumbled pictures. Wait,
so this is the same girl though? No, yes.
That I like. Are we still meeting up?
It's been a fucking eight minutes.
We're still going. Okay. I probably
should have said right there. Okay.
Cancel this day. And then we had a good
time. And so then you had a good time.
Had a good time. Okay. And
then that data ends. Yeah.
And then we had plans and uh,
I wasn't feeling great, so I,
you know, told her I wasn't
feeling great and uh, I was like,
why don't I give you 1%, uh,
uh, are you free Tuesday,
which is the next day, you
know, the next available we had,
we had a Monday date, two
could, how about Tuesday?
Cause I wanted to make sure I was
100% or are you getting Sunday?
Where are you getting sick?
Yes.
Wasn't feeling Sundays when you went to
paint and drink? No. When did you go?
A week earlier. Okay. And then
Sunday you hit her up like, yeah,
we'd been texting and it was cool.
And then, um, we decided Monday we'd,
we'd see each other again.
But when Sunday came around,
I knew she was sensitive up day of stuff.
So I said,
let me tell her now just in case I'm not,
I'm feeling worse tomorrow.
I don't want to cancel on her that day.
It'll ruin everything.
I'll tell her today, hey, I'm not
feeling 100% well how about Tuesday?
Just so I have enough extra day. I
thought that was okay. She wrote to that.
To be honest,
I'm kind of feeling unsure about you
and the things you tell me anyways.
I hope you find what you're looking for.
Good luck on your bumble dates. He's sign
what's going.
So she thought that you were okay,
so I'm also not wrong and that she's,
she's wildly insecure,
which is at a certain, especially at a
certain age, you just really shouldn't.
You don't have time for it anymore.
You don't have the energy for it.
You know what mean to insecurity,
but she's also,
that's heightened by a bit of loca.
She's kind of crazy.
[inaudible] she thinks that he's
lying to her. That's what I'm saying.
She's so insecure.
Like I don't get get she needs reassurance
every day and she feels like you were
alone or off by telling her, hey, tomorrow
is not good. How about the next day?
That's normal. Okay. See, I mean,
this story isn't over, even though
we all want it to be, it's not,
she texted me the next day, Hey, I just
re-read your texts from last night.
I think I misinterpreted the whole
thing. She said this. I thought,
I thought it sounded like
something else until I reread it.
I worked 36 hours and didn't sleep much.
I just wanted to talk to,
I'm sure I'm reading it wrong.
Oh my God, I might be an idiot.
And then she called me, I didn't pick
up and then she said, please call off.
You didn't already, uh,
block my number. Um,
and then today she texted, now I'm
sick. Karmas real. This all sucks.
Is it me? No, I, now I have to give her
some credit. Okay. I give her credit.
She went back. She may be
reacted emotionally. She
worked a lot. It sounded like.
Yeah. She had the self awareness to
read it and go like, oh, I fucked up.
That's a sign of actual
emotional intelligence. Yes. And,
and also being a big enough person to
admit it, which is kind of embarrassing.
So you know, if you, if you
were to be like, man, I really,
really liked her and be like,
well then that's obviously an indication
that maybe worth exploring again.
But if you don't or if you're like, I
don't have, you know, she's just not,
it was also the last time, but
the paint and sip, that text,
I didn't text her early enough at drink
the paint. She was a drink the pain. Yeah.
She um,
apologize for her texts there too.
So this is a path that is a
path to like just live on.
You're going to deal with this a
lot. Yeah. I'm not dating anymore.
Yeah.
And can I tell what an awful thing?
I think what's also happening
too is that in text message,
when you don't know somebody well,
it's misinterpreted.
So you may want to consider
actually calling and talking
to someone so that they
can hear your voice.
It seems so intimate when you call
them baseline now it's like, hey,
we, we misread each other's
texts. Absolutely. Yeah.
Really sometimes. No, we've
read, we've read text.
You've read text where you're like, you
think I'm being serious about something,
I have to call Matt mad or
whatever. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the thing is that you don't
have a connection established.
So when you're trying to establish a
connection, that's probably why she's,
but for her to fly off the
handle and then come back again,
that is going to be her
pattern, not, not for me.
I know the kind of girl
she's,
she's weird swearing.
They light very light.
Laughy girls' night and
not like too insecure.
You need the smash first dog.
This is what you need to do it.
Do it. I forgot. All right,
go on Tinder. Yeah. Wait,
I'm too old to be on 70 no tender. Let
me have worked with my man for a second.
So go on Tinder.
Throw up a couple like good pics.
Okay. Shirtless. No, no, no.
Nothing to nothing ridiculous with
joke. You just like good picks up. Okay.
Bio Line can be charming.
Funny,
but not like we're not doing a bit
here. Right? So you just like, whatever.
You keep it loose this way.
It's like you're not, don't put,
I'm looking for a relationship.
Just like whatever you like to do for,
I like to drink, paint and
I like to blah, blah, blah,
but you put that in there and then let
it ride. Man. Just see what kind of
work with my friend is bro.
You get out there around a little bit,
chuck it around,
clean the system.
Now you forget about the bed stalker.
You forget about drink the paint.
You get a few nuts out and
then we clean the system.
Then we delete Tinder and we
go on more of a serious match.
Last relationship thing, classes.
You need to bust those nuts first.
Get your swagger. Yeah, that's exactly
what I lost it. I had to get it back.
Why don't we get it back? All right, I'll
go on Tinder. Here's a scenario though.
No one.
I get no matches.
I mean I'm running bumble and hinge
and I'm not matching with anybody.
Let's look at your photos. I got
it right here. I'm not a chef.
She's great at the profile
that I see the profile,
my profile
comedian and a known comedian like,
here's the thing,
girls always do like the funny guys.
That's what they say.
You should exploit your celebrity
for this tender. Absolutely
exploit your celebrity.
I'm serious.
Just fix what's your bio line
and then.dot. Like 400,000
followers on Instagram.
Anyway. Make it like, oh,
okay. Here's my profile
profile pic. I first of all
this first picture is douchey.
That's fine,
but it's like
some slots or texting you talking
about what is all for fuck's sake,
man. Oh my God, Kyle. This
is how your dates are going.
This is how my life is,
bro. You know Bro, that's
why you're not matching.
This is why it's too jokey.
Let's see, and the girls, the girls
who want to just get laid are like,
this guy's too much of a
client. I know. Take a photo.
It looks like it's two. Jen's
a little jokey. It's all great.
I'm not saying you don't look
good, you look amazing. It's just,
it's too jokey. Joe and Rick,
are there other pictures?
Let's do the follow up. I'm not even sure
I do that. Okay, hold on. I'm opening.
I'm looking forward pussy and
I am trying to, all right,
there's a real photo, but that's, you
can't even see his face look like.
That's another problem. Well, what's
the last one? Let me see what Bro.
I look back that. Oh my God.
Deb. Chef. See you can't see.
You can't see very cool tree. No. Okay,
so you were your profile games wrong?
Yes.
It's good to know the first picture of,
he's kind of too jokey.
So the girl was like,
Nah, he's not serious.
And then you have a picture of a tree and
then your face is dark and by shadows.
Let's just go three tree real.
Let's use your three real pictures. Not
a pro picture. I literally don't have,
can we? But let me tell you,
here's how you going to get legs.
Here's how you're going to get laid.
You're going to have one with you
standing behind a microphone on the stage.
Girl love comedian. Now how
do you know the shit? No,
let's turn this [inaudible] all this
shit because I'm friends with your slip.
Make sure
he's got all wet when you talk,
cause I talked to girls who are dating
at the comedy store and normal girl
holding a microphone.
Oh my God. He's funny.
I love funny guys.
I'm saying like second, third
picture, but not your lead.
Your lead is just like
a normal guy staring at
I don't think.
I don't think you lead with the mic.
I didn't say he said the second or
third is I love comedy with that one you
should use if you do the mic.
The mic one.
Do you have a Pro Mike? That's
professional. Oh this is what he prefers.
I got this one just now.
You guys that good smiling and I
got a mic. Pretty good. Natural.
Pretty good.
Yeah, I like it. Yeah, we need you.
We're going to do a complete review.
I don't like online dating.
I think I'm just going to co a break.
Yeah, but I will check. I'll
take those pictures down now.
I felt very self conscious or just
switch them around. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you have any head shots that are like,
just aren't those headshot?
It's worse. Smash, smash city, Bro. Dude,
I don't put a picture of you
with somebody else. Like, Hey,
it's me and this other guy,
because then people go, well,
which guys that I know that's silly.
Don't do you want to have a
picture with some friends?
They'll just get friends because then
the girl goes, well I just want to,
if you just have, if you crop
arms out. So in other words,
if it was friends
with his friends and
an Arrow off the thing,
there's friends over their friends over
there. Okay. Now I will say the dog.
Very appealing. Absolutely.
Take care of something.
You can take care of something
that you are capable of love.
Here's the thing though,
we don't want to make your smash
profile the same as your cause.
There's the relationship profile. Get
my Dick web profile should be different.
Definitely different than I think my
bros. Right on that, but smash profiles.
Then the dumb chick's got, am I god, I
love doggy here. That's what I'm saying,
but it's good the dog.
It's the honey honey.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're going to help you with this.
I'll keep you guys up to date.
You really will want to know.
I want to know. I want to know.
I'll let you guys know when I smash.
Dude, you got to smash. It's so gross,
isn't it? I mean, I think it's
beautiful. This'll be you in a week.
Pictures are going to profile pleasures.
It's going to be hot, aren't you?
When you're done, just like, oh, well
what did we do after you smash? Yeah.
It's weird thing, right? She would a
stranger. Who are we now? What was that?
I'm never done it, but that's why
he needs, he needs that cleanse.
I've gone to a party Saturday
meal. Just smash out there. It did.
Probably party is a good place to do it,
man. Maybe you can get out of the way.
Skipped the whole Tinder thing. I
think he'd be a good wing man. For me.
It'd be like, oh great. My broke Kyle, you
mean my bro. Oh, I would bet right there.
Now I'm looking good. I would come
up with stories. That would be,
I would be telling his Dick,
he fucking, there's this IPO.
You know what that is introduced me
to like 25 million than you. Anyways.
What do you guys,
uh,
are you guys going out to a diner
afterwards or what kind of hungry?
Suddenly they're like, wait,
what's an IPO? I'll be like, ah,
fuck you know what your game is by
the way. Yeah. What is his game?
This is a perfect game. Your
game. When we were dating. Oh,
contemptuous and difference.
A little bit of silent indifference.
When I met Tom,
he was 23 and he was just kind of quiet,
but like a quiet, you
know what I mean? Like,
like not like a puppy dog, like excited
to meet you, like kind of like whatever.
I don't give a shit. Like,
his whole vibe was like,
I don't care whether or not any of this
fucking happens in your life. Yeah.
It takes the, it takes the ease. There's
no desperation there. So you're like, oh,
what's going on with, what's he
all about? I bet he's excited.
He's in the waterfalls to fed,
but then you go to his house and you're
like, oh, this guy's like no game.
Because he sleeps on a mattress on
the floor and he doesn't use soap.
You could sell that. I was not
yet a little bit of contempt.
I do the whole thing. I still do. I know
I bought a Tesla so
I'm going to have a serious car game.
Really. I got Honda Civic. You bought it.
You need a Tesla.
I should maybe return it.
Why was really expensive,
but you bought it. Yeah,
it's going to help. It's going to help
the smash game for sure. Let's just do it.
Chicks loved dogs and Nice cars
get more dogs, more Teslas.
My game is like, like yours except
add the crippling insecurity.
We all are insecure.
That's the thing.
That's the thing you
realize as you get older,
once you're in a secure
relationship and everything,
you see more how insecure you were
and you realize that everybody is,
and then that, that's what happens
is like once you're not in the hunt,
you're like, oh, why is everybody
so fucking insecure? You know?
But you need to be like locked
down to dating. So brutal.
I mean put yourself out there every
single time you meet somebody and then
people who date without booze I'm
impressed with does first couple of days
during that first kiss without
being drunk. Magic trick.
I don't know how people do their
first kiss. I've been talking,
I talk about it on stage now.
The level of tension for for an opening,
that first kiss,
I mean it is like,
it's nauseating just to like weather.
Like when you go like I got a coach,
if you're, especially if
you're the guy, he's the guy,
you're supposed to be the initiator,
you know, you can't do it. Like,
like I had women who had said
like, don't ask. That's the worst.
That makes me crazy as,
and it's growing like don't ask,
but now you have to ask you,
you don't ask.
It's never asked you gotta you gotta
you gotta be very clear though.
In this day and age you
got to have a lot of cures.
The thing you get the
clues and then like look,
the absolute worst thing. I mean,
yeah. Someone being like, oh no,
but like where you really that misled.
You know what I mean?
Like I don't feel like I was
ever that misled terms of like,
I never went for a kiss
and had someone go like,
what the fuck he had the,
I've had it happen to me when I'm saying
read cues and he went for it and I was
like, I did throw him off. Yeah. But how
often does that happen? I was drunk too.
It's weird that that's why you
must read this guy. Yeah. But
that's why you misread you were drunk.
It was like if you're not drunk,
let's say you're sober or
you have a glass of wine,
you're in a situation where that kids
can happen mean there's like a woman is
going to give you all kinds
of body Hughes look. Yeah,
I mean like you're kind of pick up on it.
I know it's whether you have the
confidence to go for it, but it's like,
are you really this whole thing of like,
can I kiss you?
Aw Man. I see it in reality
shows and I'm like, oh,
how many first kisses have
you had since we'd had ours?
I think she was from our first
one when we had our first kiss.
That was probably oh five and
probably not more than 10 since then.
Of like where I went out with a girl and
I wasn't sure whether you guys swing.
Oh yeah. That's cool. Okay. Yeah.
We're poly and by he buys. Yeah,
we're probably probably by SIS.
Yeah. Well you got everything going.
Yeah, we got to do this real quick.
One second, Kyle. Let's make some
money. Let's make some cheese.
Kyle, one thing that's going
to help wherever that smile.
Let's see what we always do. Be Honest.
Don't be like, but really smile for us.
Let us really see a smile.
Genuine smile.
You have nice teeth, really good
teas. Are Those yours? Are Those,
wait, no, I do have good teeth.
You profile. Realize braces.
Oof. I do. Sometimes you do the
home strips or do you go to like,
there's like this thing you paint on.
It's not like a paintbrush.
What is it that come was put
the cum all over your face. Wow.
On the cheeks and then,
and then I have this a retainer where
like once a week and I'll just seriously,
now let's put it in that.
That's enough.
This is from the dentist or
you just buy this dentist?
I would say, yeah. Yeah. Again,
we do dental updates quite often and
we have a lot of guests come in here.
They show his teeth. Sometimes we
have to be a little nicer to them.
I would say those are top
three teeth we've ever seen.
That straight man clean.
Now you could tell me those are veneers
as this really what's going on? Hey,
I think we have a new profile pic.
That's what I'm thinking. Yeah.
Close up of the teeth.
Yes.
Actually don't you feel like when you
see someone's teeth it really toe? Oh,
it tells the whole story and it makes
you attracted, you know, so much.
I mean there's like someone especially
who's young and has like already yellow
in between. There's just, they're
just going to bed with a s, you know,
when I don't like, by the way, I know
that we all have, you know, we're,
there's different stages of life where
different levels of income and what you
can spend on it.
I hate someone telling me like,
like especially if they're employed,
they have a decent job and it's like, ah,
it just fuck this part. Like, no,
you need to direct your
funds into this region.
If you have a job that
gives you any resources,
put down the plastic, rack up the
debt and you take care of the mouth.
Yup. Don't let that shit slide. It's hard
to go. You know, you go to the dentist,
get teeth cleaned every six months.
They say every three months. How often?
Every six too.
Who's got time for that?
But they said the plaque and your gums
deal and your life quicker to, absolutely.
I mean these are basically bones
in your face that other people see.
Although I have a theory that it's not
the, you don't take care of your teeth.
It just if you build up
plaque easily on your teeth,
maybe you build up plaque
easily in your arteries theory.
I have but I haven't heard
that and I don't know much
so uh, that might be wrong.
I got to get my teeth cleaned.
Actually I'm going to make an appointment.
I had an appointment and then
those fires happened. Fires. Fuck.
Are we kind of move
Dennis to out here though?
Well then we have to go in and
get the x rays and do the console.
We're going to go back to the other one.
I it depends.
Do you want to go start with a new guy
out here and then we got to go to this is
the whole thing and shit.
Fuck yeah.
Cause right now we have more
so much transfer the x rays,
too many extras. No, that your thyroid
cancer. This is linked to that.
Dr. Ross just said that you
have to wear a thyroid guard,
will send us all kinds of clips. I don't
know if you know this or not. I do.
You always watch things that people send.
Somebody sent this.
Let me see what it says about her.
This lady. Okay, so the light was red.
She was reading a piece of paper. The
light turned green. She continued to read,
so I pressed the horn quickly.
Then she continue reading,
so I pressed it longer until
the light changed to red again.
She got out of her car and argue with me
that she was reading the paper because
she felt dizzy and wanted to know if
she could turn around to go back to cvs.
I tried backing up to around her and
then she walked into the other lane and
then I started recording. So this guy
had dinner with a woman. Just being real.
You're blocking the road.
[inaudible]
if the card,
it's simple, just move it to
the side of the road. Really?
[inaudible]
oh, sandals. These are
definitely the I give up.
That's what I'm saying. And that
shirt lady at my phone. Yeah.
She could swipe which way?
It was the hot, the light was red.
The light was red. It turned green.
You still sat there reading a
piece of paper, turn red again.
You
can't just sit here.
Okay,
phone
call the police,
get away,
get away.
I'm always on the side of the
Fedex drivers. Yo, fucking hard.
That job is and this dumb
bitch just get out of traffic.
You stupid cow deliver all
day. Oh my God. Real work man
around and you just did go, go, go, go.
And then this fucking dope dumb shit.
Just have a problem every day of
her life and makes it a problem.
Not a problem. Yeah, she's one
of those, right? Always a victim.
I just did this for three seconds.
Change cause she was reading,
you know the numbers
on the side of the truck.
Simple call.
You
call the police
for being so now she got what she
wanted. She got her, got her apology.
You're sitting at a green light
over.
Yeah.
I could see through your window
you were reading a piece of paper.
Pull over.
Right.
Waste of everybody's Day.
You're not aware of late.
When I picked the morning,
Christine,
I'm not giving it
to this woman. Go right ahead. Much
money and be serious.
Like,
what's the lowest you would
take to make love this woman?
You have to be very nice. Whisper
nice things or air. She's the lowest.
Absolute lowest you would
take. [inaudible] okay,
let's really be realistic.
Yeah. Christina doesn't find out about
it or I'll give you full consent.
I'm totally on board cause
I want the money now.
You know it's getting sloppy
that things aren't going great.
She looks like a mess. She's,
it's smells bad, Emily.
Her feet are horrendous. They've wouldn't
wearing those Birkenstock sandals.
You gotta I contact her
mouth to mouth.
You can't turn her on her stomach.
You have to do a missionary.
You have to look her in the eye
when he's first gotta get her going.
He gotta do some work downstairs. Be
Realistic and I'm, I want a real number.
Don't be like your lighting. Yeah.
Yeah. The lowest. Think about your life.
Do you mean you got to finish
right and eye contact. Eye contact.
Not Looking at her in the eye and say,
I'm not a
last second will I was the Fedex guy.
Spirit animals.
I think be realistic.
I don't want you to
$20,000 $20,000 a lot of are you?
Why would people pollute
me? Do you know? You know,
honestly what I was thinking for real
before you said that, I swear to you,
when I was thinking like I was
trying to figure out the number,
the first number hand to God on our
children in my mind was $5 million.
What I was thinking, it's the lowest.
That's what I was like. If someone say,
here's 4 million can say running
through in my head and was like, okay,
and I was like, should I say five? Oh,
stop. Be Realistic now let's think about,
I was being real.
Let's bring it down.
Rockefeller talking about coming in this
lady after sweet kisses and eating her
box. Yeah, you did. You take
a look what I'm dealing with.
You want me to, she sat there in her
face. She's got some good qualities. Good.
That hair, her skin looks
soft. She's very white. She,
you're like 20 grand.
Maybe you would do it for 20 grand
and if you can't finish, you don't.
You don't get anything like you've
gone through the whole thing and that's
pressure on you that you may not
be able to. Okay, so let's go.
Let's work in reverse. You had made a good
point. You said someone said 4 million.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah, absolutely.
3 million. Let's be real.
I'm like, you lie, you million dollar.
Let me work. You ruined this line.
Million. You're ruining this. We're
ruining this. You're ruining this.
Why are you ruining this?
Ruining what?
I'm working through it and you're like
jumping your care fears. I don't leave.
Christina knows how serious it doesn't
understand. It's too preposterous.
4 million.
Tom's taking this really seriously and
I'm trying to figure this out and you're
real. You're like 20 grand. Like I
would even spit on her for 20 minutes.
I would spit on her for 20
grand. I wouldn't, I'd be
like, it's not enough money.
Okay. It might, it might throw up
on her for 20 grand. If I had vomit,
like backed up,
I might puke on it for 20 minutes.
Max Funding that you puking on this woman.
I'm saying 1 million.
Think about cash tax free.
I give you a suitcase of $1 million,
you're not going to do this for one.
I don't think it's enough. Really.
I don't think it's enough. I really don't.
I don't think you that's impressive.
I'm way below that. Yeah. I think, I
think, I think on, if I'm being honest,
I would say like two,
two and a half would be like
the bottom wow. To do it.
You definitely have more money than
I do. Kyle, what's your bottom?
I'm like in the teens. Come on to
you got to eat or box for a while.
Got a banger and you got to
look in her eyes as you finish.
I'm definitely under a hundred grand.
I'll tell you that right out of the box.
Um, you have to, you have
to eat her ass for a while.
Way Her ass. Yeah. You added that. No,
that's always there. I played. He's right.
It is always there.
Well,
we didn't say that with you. I just
threw it in there. I had through it.
How am I,
what kind of ass is it licking you?
Getting in there deep.
Is it how long? Yeah. Liggett,
one rim, and I'm back to,
uh, her lady parts. Poke it a little
bit with your tongue. All right.
A couple of pokes, rim and then,
okay, well let me ask you though.
You got to jump into,
you need to have,
you got a 69 being realistic
here. Oh, are you serious?
And she's wearing that
outfit.
That's awesome. I love
that. That's a real factor.
She keeps telling you about this FedEx
guy that annoyed her the whole time.
Okay, sorry. So I have to 69 and if you
have to succeed her butthole, I will not,
I will not going to lick her butthole.
How about we go to your $1 million
cash bag? You're like, nope,
it's $1 million in cash.
Here's saying I would do it for a million.
Yeah.
Cash tax free.
The IRS never say no to 900,000
cash. It has to be a million in
my mind for it to be worthwhile.
I have to have that amount.
So now I don't seem so preposterous to,
you have a one millions less
preposterous and five to two and a half.
Christina, you don't get any of the money.
It's harder for a woman. So work. Hey,
that's way harder for me. I Dunno. I mean,
do I have to come or does she have to?
Everybody is at a party. She
has to come. Whoa, Whoa, whoa.
You said I had to come and look at it.
We don't know her biology.
She may not be able to. Okay.
Let's say, let's say she can,
no, not different game. Different story.
We have to make her sick.
There's no way I'd spend the
time. You have money. That's
been the time. They know.
Wait a minute. Does that change your
fee though? So what's your fee now?
$400,000 and you'll make her come.
I will make that woman and
have the greatest night of
her life. I believed you.
And that's your Tinder game.
You need to go into your status came up.
I want you to think about her.
Every time you're on,
you're going to do it. I'm not doing
Tinder is too for the kids. Do it, man.
I'm 47 so what? 47 on Tinder, bro.
We're just trying to clear the
pipes little bit. That's true. See,
Christina is what says is embarrassing.
I mean grow up.
You have to give her an orgasm and you
have to do by any means necessary mouth
if to use your mouth, your hands,
your painter. I think six is fine.
Six Mil. Yeah. I know you
guys have a good life.
Do you know that? Like
do you, do you recognize
that like we have a really good life
because most people get used to their life
and they go, oh my life. It's fine.
Are you like that or do you know that
you just come down here and talk about
this and I need,
we appreciate it greatly.
Cool. We get to do this.
I got paid $6 million to make.
This lady can realize how good my life is.
Pretty sweet.
6 million.
See what I mean by the way?
I framed it like that to me and you
show me the bags and then you're like,
it's, she's right through there.
I would go in there with these,
this attitude of like,
daddy going to make you calm.
So like do whatever you want. You want
to Fart in my face and get started.
I would just absolutely
mental state a really like,
I think I would leave
there and she'd be like,
it needs to get a bonus because I
came like 16 times. Oh you know,
I think I would go in there
like let's up the ante.
There's bonus checks you do a whole night
with her and you got to do it as many
times as she, as many times as she wants.
And you have to do whatever she wants.
She's not in good shape.
She would. She wouldn't,
she wouldn't be like more
and more and more and more.
You've got to nut three times in 12 hours,
12 hours,
12 hours. I think it's doable.
I don't think I can do it.
I think you can eat a diet nuts and then
you'll get any money cause you could,
couldn't do your third nut.
Oh,
key is you want, you want those
first two as fast as you can. I,
you can [inaudible] period's going to
really dwell after that second one and
then when it's like, hey man, we got
two hours left. You'd be like, hey,
why don't you fucking smack them
around a little bit to get going here,
but can you brought up a great point is
that you're going to have her like butt
juices and all her juices like,
oh, you're just smell to be.
I was just thinking about
those millions though.
I can't believe you thought I was going
to do this for $20,000. I'm serious.
I might do it for 20 grand.
Really?
I'm going to get 20 grand tax free.
Make a woman feel good for a little while.
It's beautiful thing.
She's a good night. Good night.
It's tax free. Can we regroup?
Will you tell me for real what
you would need to eat her box?
I'm being be real. Look at
her. No, she's disgusting.
I would say this is what the Moose
suit lady looks like. Muscle building.
We actually saw her. It looks much
better. She does. Most of it looks better.
I'm serious. I'm serious. She does.
Seriously is my nightmare.
If I were to go gay,
this is not my
voice.
Like that's who I am. So you imagine?
Yeah, and I'm being honest and sincere.
When I say $1 million cash
and nobody finds out about it.
That's another thing.
You can't be on the Internet and
you'd have to make her come. Yeah.
And I'm being serious. So you'd
want a lot of effort into it, right?
For a million cash. Cash. Like if you
came out of there, she didn't come.
You'd be like,
I really tried.
Yeah.
Was $1 million a ton.
Mike. Let's say you just walked
out right now and she didn't come.
Would you be like, I'd be so
bomb. Do Cause I want that
money. But you'd be like,
I really ate as much as I got fucked
up. I would make it happen. Yeah.
I'm going to flip the script on you,
Tom.
She straps on a Dildo. Okay.
You've got to take it. Okay.
For five minutes as she is yelling at
you as you makes you wear a FedEx outfit.
Yeah. Easy. Five minutes. Oh, okay.
Now we can start talking to that
bullshit money. Okay. What is it,
50 grand and bulldozed by her? Yeah. Yeah.
The strap on. Yeah. No,
but I might do it for like six figures
or something because I feel like there's
no, like that I'm facing a wall, you know,
I'm looking away and the
things being done to me. See,
I find that much more
violating. Oh No. See that.
I could check out of that and look, I
could check out. Yeah, I agree with Tom.
You can check out, you'd go, I
would check out and she'd be like,
I fucking ups is better. And
I'd be like, Eh, all right.
And then she just rails me and I would
just kind like, just be like, that's fine.
I've never had that done to me.
So it also is a scary,
but peg is one. I neither have. I
neither is he right? Tom [inaudible].
He seems pretty cavalier about it. I just
feel like, yeah, I just feel like, uh,
that,
that one's not,
I feel like doing things to her would
require much more out of me. Okay. Yeah,
I think it was. I'm glad we
figured out. Yeah, that's her.
That's her. That's the elk. That's
who you're dealing with. Dirty bic.
Aoun. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh,
dirty son of a
Kyle. Have you ever smoked meth? No.
Yeah. What is your drug history like?
I was pretty much a square and then
I've recently done a lot of marijuana at
night to sleep. That's
nice. Do jellies. And uh,
I used to take those a diazo
Pam's or whatever that, those uh,
or Lunesta and I'd find
the marijuana is not as,
I don't get as hung over and it seems
like it doesn't affect me in a negative
way. I hope. It seems like it's okay
though. Cool. What do you guys do?
Wine Party? No, little bit of Mary Jane.
Sometimes I want to try mushrooms.
Never done it. I haven't either.
I want to try that. Should do it.
What if you were to, by the way,
since you know how he's singing and
we're trying to hook him up. Hmm.
What if he went into like a new
facet, like a new genre, a new,
a new lane instead of like traditional.
Okay.
What if you step out of the box a little
bit, you know in terms of in what way?
Well, what if you did something
like that? You forgive him for that
thinking.
This is a meal with the red point,
but the cost is actually contained blood.
Leah,
now I want your average couple.
They're actually real life vampires
living in the sleepy town of Haven hills
suffered the taste of
the blood on the person.
Maybe that's your lady. All right. Right.
How much do you make her come for? Fuck.
Is this our new game?
I would have an easier time with her
because she's got a real look that I could
get into.
Can I tell you something right away that
I feel like already what she would like.
Even if you weren't attracted
or like she knows what's up,
she knows how to do things. She could
hurt you though. She could hurt you,
but she'd also be like,
I know what feels good.
She's worked her way around a nut sack
for sure. That's what I'm saying guys.
You're frying to golf checks,
which I'm an expert in. Yeah.
There's two kinds of God chicks. You
got your skinny goth chick. Yeah.
And then your heavier goth chick who
wears like a lot of latex and very not
porous materials around their blue jeans.
Uh, I get, I know what you're gonna do.
You know what I'm saying? So it's
not the best. That's what I've heard.
So I would take that into
consideration cause she's,
she's wearing leather
and stuff in that area.
It was love at first bite all the time.
Vampire Arrow,
often Mitera dating website on Valentine's
Day when I first saw that he was a
vampire is very interesting.
I was like, okay,
didn't know that was actually a
proper real vampires out though.
You always hope there was.
I hope to have children. She, he looks
terrifying. Yeah. I mean she's like,
you know,
it looks like kind of like almost looks
I'm going to hate hosting parties.
No,
but I'm saying,
I feel like I see that she tried
to put this together with him.
I see like a genuine scary fucking guy,
right?
Like this is how he naturally look
like there's no effort, vampires,
murder people. So he's gotta be at least
entertaining those thoughts in his head.
Yeah. Even as a fantasy, that's
a part of the lifestyle.
The blood always had cravings
for pledge since the first day.
I can remember anytime someone cut
their self, if they cut their finger,
I'd put their finger in my mouth. If
they're all odd, clap my mouth over it.
Right.
He's
Gary.
Oh yeah.
The teeth aren't good to any black
lipstick highlights yellow teeth.
This is what your boyfriend's looked
like back then. Yeah. Yeah. I mean,
not like him, but like the saying, the
black lipstick eyeliner. Pretty much.
Same as the old dude, that big book. Duplo
but we didn't drink blood were lunatics,
uh, when she has her period. Right.
All right. Ask. Keep it going.
And most shockingly level,
they drink each other's blood.
Hello.
Are All my saw come wild
covered? No, the laptop.
Couple of set to get married on the
spookiest there for year Halloween coding.
Uh, God, it's eerie. So
unsure of how her family was,
take the news of her unusual lifestyle.
She hasn't yet told them it's
actually happy with the relationship.
They don't look healthy. Yeah.
A great way to get. Yeah,
it happened. You know, I was convinced
I had aids in 1990, like not even,
I think I might have.
It was like I knew I had aids,
how I had never had sex with a girl
before and I came home from this party,
it was a college and she's like,
Kyle done, I get to get up here.
She's drunk.
And we had sex really fast and she
was 21 which seemed sold to me.
And if she had sex with me, like
she's probably, as you know, very, uh,
so this is 1990 [inaudible]
you had unprotected sex,
you got a, that was like what they
were saying. Right. So I was couldn't,
Vince and I left there and I was,
I was really upset and I
ran into my roommate at the
time who was like this jock
guy and I, and I, I embarrassed myself.
I was like crying and I was
like, yeah, I was crying.
I was like that.
Like we get like one word out,
like just got aids and then, um, anyway,
but it actually helped out because
later on I never got tested because you
couldn't get tested on campus. And then
I was going to this Billy Joel concert,
right. This all gets back
to AIDS. Okay. And, um,
in the back and I'm so far
away at Yankee stadium, you're,
he's playing piano, man. You're,
you're hearing uptown girl this sound.
So we sneak down, I get to the front
row and I'm going to jump on stage.
You know what? You know, it
was a huge Billy Joel Fan.
Like I'm gonna die anyways.
I got aids. That's what I thought. Really?
I wasn't going to do it. I chicken doubt.
And then I remembered, oh, I have a,
I'm gonna own Dynamic and the
power of aids propels you,
jumped on stage and they
filmed it that night. And, uh,
I have the film of me jumping on
stage. Are you being serious? Yeah,
it's on my Instagram. And then I
can pull up your Instagram. Yeah.
It's like one of the first videos
I posted and then, um, yeah,
and then years later, 25 years
later, almost to the day I,
I was on stage with Billy Joel randomly.
Uh,
like how you're casually like yeah,
I was going say we'll,
Amy Schumer had his songs in
her movie and she basically up,
cause she knew I liked Billy Joel and
she just put them in now you know,
for the other character is way down here.
It's like one of the first guys
I posted. Okay. So Amy Hill,
so she was invited on stage. Is it cause
uh, to like dance during uptown girl.
And so she invited me.
So I went and met him during rehearsal
and it was so eerie because it was the
same like outdoor stadium.
He was in the same spot.
I was in the same spot and like I went
up the same way. It just was very eerie.
Cool. How long ago, by the way, is your
neck twisting injury? Was that from uh,
think I was like 24.
Okay.
So we're running the limo
driver at all these photos.
Look at all these photos, trying to figure
out how to do Instagram at that point.
That's a character though. Lost cause
did you tell Billy Joel your aid story?
I did. I didn't say aids, but told him
the story. I'd be jumping on stage.
I showed him the video and I have the
video one is really cool. He was cool.
But I mean I, you know Jennifer Lawrence
was there too and he's probably, if I,
if they weren't there, he would have
been like at the get away from me,
get away from me dude. The
fuck are you? He's like,
oh there it is. It is where they would
go up. Oh that's no, sorry. Go down
to the right is like the
rehearsal for the one. Yeah. Yeah.
That'd be showing them,
yes.
You showing him the video video
of me jumping on stage with AIDS.
Let's see how I want to see how
much disdain he has for you in this.
He doesn't like me. Let's
see, let's see if he,
cause I,
I think it was nice. Cool
is very cool. Yeah. Yeah.
I didn't know.
I can't imagine being that famous is
Billy Joel and people just freak out every
time they see you or he was doing,
he might be still be doing it.
You know some places you get a residency,
they have a residency in Vegas.
He had or maybe still has a residency.
He does Madisonville cheese
and his commute to work.
A helicopter lands in his lawn and
the flies. It's like Garth level,
they gas arena. I like your golf posts.
What the hell is going on in here?
That's a topless book.
I was trying to make
Tinder.
That's a good Tinder shot course.
You're going to get laid on that. You
are a man, Bro. We're trying to get,
thank you. No, that's cool. I didn't,
I thought that was like the opposite of
a something that would turn women on.
How about the upper right
for Tinder? Nope. Nope, nope,
nope. Oh boy. Oh yeah. There it
is. Dire. She is. This is it here?
Is this you? Yeah, that's me. That's me.
This girl.
She was okay.
Jumping on the stage here to jump
out of that. That was like, Oh,
I'm narrating this. Sorry.
Give me the courage.
You pat them on the path as you said. It's
good job. Answer this guy. I'm like, Hey,
watch out. Don't touch. Is this the end
of the show that he's doing this? Yeah,
it was right at the end to jump up then.
It was cool.
Good job. He just looks at you. It's kind
of fun. He's like, it's kind of cool.
He's like that guy. I
know. That's my ability,
Joel Freak out at all. He
was like, guys on stage.
It's awesome. Alright. Uh, anywhere,
do you have coming up any tour
dates or anything like that?
Yeah.
You got where you come? I'm going
to be at the Largo Theater, uh,
December 18th in Los Angeles and then
I'm doing a tour like in February ish,
which hasn't, oh, she'll be on
my website. Okay. Kyle Dunnigan,
comedy.com. And you're very, very funny.
Instagram is co at Kyle going to get one.
If you could refer to me
as the king of Instagram,
that would help me out that I have no
problem with that goal. Um, and then,
let's see, we have a, you
have anything to add, gene?
Anything else to throw in there?
The Christina on Instagram.
And not to be confused with
all the other Christina piece.
I'm cigarette Tom Cigarette top sick
where I flipped it because at the time,
16 year old British boy named Tom
Screw ahead at times. Girl. Yeah,
someone has Christina p the
Christina p this song, uh,
we always have a listener made songs.
Dj Double Pipe made this, it's called,
I fucking want to get horny in
parentheses. Try it out. Nice. Okay, cool.
So Kyle, thank you for coming. Thank you
Jean. Thanks for being here. Thank you,
Tami Todd. I had fun with you,
Christine. Do you Tim bye.
Gene by gene.
Joe.
Sam,
sorry.
Yeah.